e
you
the chair recognizes from Auburn
represent Osborne who moves at the house
to journ from the session of April 11th
2024 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those and close nay
the eyes have it the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
Simpson thank
morning let us be in a mindful Spirit of
Good Will As We Gather today
source of light god of love creator of
all as spring blooms around us open our
hearts and our minds to the
possibilities of New Life ground Us in
the solid earth beneath our feet as we
lift our eyes to the fresh leaves and
fill us with Good
Will to help us Center hear these words
from the suda nepata a discourse from
the Buddha on
Goodwill may all beings be filled with
with joy and peace may all beings
everywhere the strong and the weak the
Great and the small the mean and the
powerful the short and the long the
subtle and the gross may all beings
everywhere seen and unseen dwelling far
off or nearby being or waiting to
become may all be filled with lasting
Joy let no one deceive another
let no one anywhere despise another let
no one out of anger or resentment wish
suffering on anyone at all just as a
mother with her own life protects her
child her only child from harm So within
yourself let grow a boundless Love For
All
Creatures Let Your Love flow outward
through the universe to its height its
depth its broad extent a limit less love
without hatred or
enmity then as you stand or walk sit or
lie down as long as you are awake strive
for this with one pointed mind your life
will bring Heaven to
the chair recognizes a member from
blinds in a Lisa post who will lead us
Allegiance
Al of the United States of America
the stands
na
the chair now recognizes Wilton lber
School chorus who will sing our national
anthem
the
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leav of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Connor levit sfus and
vanney the day important business
Representatives William Dolan foot
infantine genesian Lehman O'Hara sellers
smart Tetro Traer Len turot and Vincent
the day illness in the family
represented fedus and
shamberg these leaves of option shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Dar Gerard guest of
Representative Merchant Peter Weaver
Taran Anderson and Katherine Goslin
guests of Representative kohal The
Honorable Sally Kelly former member from
triester guest of Representative priest
fourth grade students from mastway
elementary school guests of
Representative wall faith renzullo wife
of Representative Rulo Priscilla Jessica
Jeff Jess and Elizabeth CLE Justin
Golding Kylie smart and laureli jackol
family of honorable guest Bob CLE guests
of the speaker they're with us in the
gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
[Music]
clerk Mr Speaker in a letter dated
yesterday Dear Mr Speaker due to an
unexpected family situation I am no
longer able to reside in my district and
must regretfully and with much respect
resign my position as state
representative for Rockingham District
30 CBR New Hampshire it's been an honor
to have served my constituents in the
great state of New Hampshire
respectfully Tina L
Harley designation accepted with regret
the house will now attend to Memorial
remarks from for the former
representative from Hudson The Honorable
Robert Cay Jr chair recognizer
Zulo thank you Mr Speaker I would ask
the delegation from Hudson to please
come join me
well got to be prepared you know when
not thank you very
much on August
Bob leaves behind his loving wife
Priscilla his do his daughter
Jessica her husband her uh and her
husband just
Justin he his son
Jeffrey and his wife
Jesse and his
grandchildren Bob's grandchildren Kylie
Laura
and
Elizabeth i' like to start at the end of
this my wife faith and I have known Bob
Cay and Priscilla cay at least some 30
years probably more have been friends
most of that
time on September 9th
2023 faith and I attended a celebration
of life for Bob at the Sheridan Tara in
nasua the celebration was supposed to
start at 1:00 p.m. so faith and I
figured we could get there by 12:30 and
beat the
rush this was held in a very big room
with a bar adjacent and it was
packed people were lined up around the
room waiting to talk to Priscilla and
Bob's
children in later conversations with
Priscilla I
learned nearly half nearly all
the folks lined up had a story to tell
about how Bob the Bob they knew and how
many of them how they were related with
we they related how Bob had helped them
in their in their lives and influence
their lives we figured the line would
lessen soon and we'd be able to uh get
in line to pay our respects never
happened people kept coming in the line
never
shortened the facility operator
estimated that some 12200 people showed
up that
day due to a health issue we had to
leave as it was approaching time to
dinner we never we never we had time to
pay our respects we had dinner with
Priscilla a month later and found out
that she never took a break from
greeting those who who came and stood in
line she wanted to hear everything they
had to
say she could do no
less I guess the old adage is
true behind every strong man is a really
strong
woman Bob k e Cay Jr was a complex man
who lived by a simple code work harder
than everybody else keep your word help
those in need and stand your ground Bob
had the ability to befriend anyone and
make them his friend he his sense of
humor his quick wit his ability to
connect with people made him
approachable and respected he also had
the Gift of Gab and could get up and
speak off the cuff these were his
natural gifts he was also a very
strategic
thinker no wonder he excelled in
politics but first Bob made a living as
a
builder he was an excellent Builder he
if you're from Nashua you probably know
the Lilac Blossom out on Amber Street in
the Greystone Plaza that was Bob's
handiwork and he was proud of it I
recall some very nice dinners
there but that was moons
ago it's been a while since I've been
weekend most of us excuse me most of of
us in this building since 1994 probably
knew Bob in a role of politician in his
four terms in the house he was an
assistant Majority Leader a majority
caucus whip which I just found out what
that was while I was walked in and the
speaker Pro Temp as Bob once said the
title means nothing it's what you do
with it that counts remember Bob first
and always was a builder you don't
survive in that business very long
without a good good
reputation or by not getting the job
done some once said with 400 members
getting things done okay with 400
members getting things done in the house
was like hurting cats through a car
wash I think I said
that he once told me he was convinced he
convinced the then speaker to let him go
in and monitor certain committees with a
blank committee appointments forms in
his
pocket which he used a in on committees
which might be having
problems he made his
reputation like to read you some
words by
someone who was who's was with Bob at
those at those
times and we these words were written in
the condolence section of the federal of
the funeral home website by soon after
Bob's passing this news is heartbreaking
Bob was not only a man of his work
he was an advocate for the best
interests of his constituents and
community that doesn't mean we always
agreed on Solutions but when we we did
things got done he was a man possessed
of real empathy and so much belief in
the institutions of New Hampshire
government I feel myself honored to have
known Bob in the House and
Senate it was spoken by Peter ho Burling
who was the house a house Democrat atic
served yeah hearken back to the Bob's
code I just talked
about the harder we
work the harder than every work harder
than everybody else and keep your word
that
was that in 2002 Bob moved on to the
Senate
actually he ran over the Senate with one
term Senator the with a one-term Sen
when a one-term senator became Senate
President and a zero term Senator Bob
becoming majority leader which he had
for three
years he got a taste for National
politics and hooked up with Arkansas
Governor Mike Tuck's presidential
campaign again these words were again
were written in the funeral home website
passing and I lost it NOP right
here dear Bob it was friends of First
Sight during a hot day in Iowa at the
state fair when you deafly took on
several young and buffed 20s something
20-some year olds to protect some rather
vulnerable volunteers on your side on
our side you probably were outnumbered
and outgunned but that didn't matter to
day
again go back to hearken back to Bob's
code help those in need and stand your
ground I'll tell you Bob was not
outnumbered you knew Bob he was big guy
and he worked out a lot he didn't sleep
much and that time at the time he didn't
sleep he was always working out so I
think they were outnumbered so Bob also
made a run for Congress in 2008 he
played second PR uh place in the primary
I refrain from commenting on what to say
about the about the Republican party at
that time other than to say we did not
have the quality of leadership in it
that we'd have to today after that Bob
became a founding partner in legislative
Solutions lobbying
organization and you know about that uh
that's history I've learned a lot more
about Bob since his passing Bob was like
an
iceberg mostly you what you an iceberg
mostly what you see is a big big mass of
ice floating on the sea that's only
10% all the the the rest the Bob was you
90% the iceberg is
underwater Bob
kept I learned
generosity after
after I Le the true extent of Bob's
generosity empathy and I learned it was
infinite and
unknowable he really did care about
others and it was part of his
code but you didn't I didn't know much
about it he didn't hide it he didn't bro
but he didn't broadcast it either he
worked with many local
groups throughout the years in support
of those less fortunate several veterans
organizations the Hudson food pantry
need needy families at Christmas F
Family Promise Southern New Hampshire
presentation of
Mary but there were many more but I just
don't know them
all
spotlight but as a generous man he hid
from the spotlight he shunned it he
didn't want people to
know I suspect one of the reasons Bob
liked to be involved in local boards and
a First
Responders and with First Responders is
because it gave him access to PE real
people
people with real needs a couple of
stories when Bob found
out from that the town welfare office
was being overwhelmed with requests for
winter clothing the next thing you know
Bob and Priscilla show up with 40 brand
new winter coats of all
sizes
another when a mutual friend of ours had
a homeless man living in a wood behind
his
house Bob came over
talked to the guy living in the woods
job last
one property renovation is a large part
of any Builder's business Bob and
Priscilla picked up some property in
hail or H Hill as they say in New
York and it was an old house it needed
major renovation including a new roof
and much and much needed and much needed
be and much needed to be brought up un
cot you can tell I just wrote this at
some time Bob heard that the mission for
children in the Upper Valley needed a
place for foster kids Bob and Priscilla
offered it to the
organization and then Bob tragically
left us and the project was in
limbo determined to make Bob's wish a
reality Priscilla finished the project
and the house is now in the hands of the
mission with Bob I learned that it was
never about the
organizations it was always about the
people from giving the fire department a
rescue boat from anonymously giving some
family's Christmas dinner to keeping 40
children warm in some winter to giving a
homeless man a
job it was all the same to Bob it was
Bob's
way now for those here who knew Bob at
least for a while I'd like you to forget
everything I said and think of the one
guy you knew Bob was one funny SOB he
was fun to be around he has ability to
keep a straight face when pulling a
you when when Senator
Carson was presenting Senate bill 68
honoring Bob to the public works and
Highway committee Cliff Newton raises
his hand and tells a story about how Bob
used to hide Cliff's name plate when
Cliff was chair a fishing game and they
all would have a laugh about
it that was
Bob patila Cay told me a story of how
Bob carpeted the office of a fellow
contractor who was on vacation with a
hideous zebra striped
carpet making the office look like
taron's recck room
he did he did replace the
finally priscella reminded me of the
time of Caesar's Palace when my wife and
I when my wife and her wife and I when
my wife yeah when my wife and her came
out of the ladi's room it was not my
wife and I came out of the ladies room
maybe it happen now but it won't be
happen then but when my wife my wife and
I when my wife and her came out of the
ladies room and saw Bob and I talking to
to some very pretty young ladies who
were definitely not part of the local
girl scout
troop well our wives and I made a beine
toward us and the young lady scurried
away and
Bob says with a straight face of a judge
honey they came over to Andy like they
knew him I figured he met up with them
on a previous
going they watched us very carefully
on he got
me I'll never know if it was it was
quick thinking on his part or that he
paid those ladies to come just to put
just to prank me and and Priscilla and
my wife
even when I was just walking in here
today and the knowing I was I was
speaking representative a stopped me to
show me pictures of a meeting a a meet
and greet at uh Bob Clay's famous garden
he had a garden built that he could
marry people he was a he was a uh uh a
Justice of the Peace but also he did a
lot of politicking there and it was but
he had a meet and greet for
uh for Mike Pence and he showed me the
pictures of the garden gnomes all over
the
lawn they were garden gnomes but they
weren't regular garden gnomes they all
when you're feeling
Smile by the way Bob's 70th birthday
Bob think about him when you want to
feel better and think about the guy you
knew if and for those who you who did
know
him I'm sorry for you thank you thank
you very much please Ry for a moment
silence in honor in memory of the former
member from Hudson honorable Robert Clay
Jr
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on criminal justice and Public Safety
pursuant to house rule 52 Senate Bill
591 is ordered to the regular calendar
by the speaker from the committee on
education Senate Bill
375 removed by Representatives Alicia
leus Granger Hull Tom Manion SRA
mcarter are there any other bills to be
removed representative Osborne moves at
the consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in the days house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it the consent
adopted under rules of the house from
the committee on Commerce and consumer
affairs Senate bill 407 FM is referred
to the committee on finance the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety Senate Bill 362 FN is referred to
the committee on finance from the
committee on education Senate Bill 217
FNA is referred to the committee on
finance from the committee on executive
departments and administration Senate
Bill 337 FN Senate Bill 369 FNA Senate
Bill 480 FN are referred to the Comm
committee on finance from the committee
on Health and Human Services and elderly
order the committee on fears Senate Bill
409 FN Senate Bill 4555 FN are referred
to the committee on finance from the
committee on resources recrent
Recreation and development Senate Bill
539 FN a is referred to the committee on
Ways and Means from the special
committee on child care Senate Bill 404
finance representative rulu moves to
special order Senate Bill 468 relative
to designating a portion of Route 111
and Hudson is the Senator Robert E Cay
Jr Memorial Highway is the first order
of business on the regular calendar
representative manula was recognize to
I'm not going to speak much of all if at
all on this motion I think
I've like to but except to apologize for
the to the body for the length of my of
my previous speaking speaking but as
they say you can't teach an old dog new
tricks especially if he's got
Alzheimer's so I'll I'd just like to
move uh Senate Bill 468 relative to the
designation designating a portion of rud
111 in Hudson as the Senator Robert E
you the motion is to special order
Senate Bill 468 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I oppose
nay the eyes
fifths Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred Senate
Bill
468 act relative to designating a
portion of Route 11 and Hudson as
Senator Robert E Clay Jr Memorial
Highway if it considered the same report
the same with a recommendation Bill
ought to pass C of Bill Boyd for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose n the
adopted and would I'd like to once again
before they leave or if they want to
stay recognize Bob Clay's Family up in
[Applause]
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred Senate Bill 359 in
act raising the age of marriage to 18
years of age considered the same report
the same with the recommendation Bill
ought to pass repr sentive Cassandra L
for the
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment Senator Vella
14558 and is recognized to speak to his
Amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker we
have voted on this topic many times
about whether a person should be uh able
to marry at 16 with their parents'
permission and the course permission
or if it should be barred
entirely up to 18 and I think that there
is another category that that this body
should
consider a lot of the uh the the
discussion inside of the committee
report had to do with whether or not
someone is mature enough to be able to
handle essentially this
decision and I believe that you know we
have this standard of 18 being able to
understand and be held responsible for
their
decisions as a general order of course
and then we have other court proceedings
that decide that that make judgments on
a case-by casee basis sometimes if
someone is incompetent even at 18 the
judge May rule that they're not able to
do certain things and if in cases where
uh a judge considers a minor and has the
opportunity to decide whether they are
capable of making this decision for
themselves that is considered uh
granting them
emancipation and in a lot of the the
negative remarks I hear from an
opposition is that you know in some
other state or some other country
someone did something
that Hoodwink the judge into granting
emancipation but I say that they are not
subject to our statute our stat statute
requires that it's in the best interest
of that minor that they live apart from
their parents for three months or
longer that they are able to be
self-sufficient both financially and in
their personal
affairs these are
not very low bars in New Hampshire and I
submit to you that if they are able to
meet these bars that they are able to
understand the consequences of their
actions and so I implore you to vote for
this amendment
to allow for those people that have been
judged by the court for it to be in
their best interest and that they are
able to understand the ramifications of
their actions that they be able to take
that action it is not an inherently
immoral action that they're doing it's
just whether or not they are capable of
understanding that action and accepting
the consequences of that action so I
hope you vote for this amendment thank
you Mr
Peto thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
with all due respect this amendment
defeats the purpose of the underlining
bill which is to raise the minimum age
of marriage to 18 the bill came to us
unanimously from the other chamber and
likewise the children and family law
committee submitted it to our consent
calendar and we would not be here
discussing this if it wasn't for an
amendment brought forth by a member not
from our committee the fact of the
matter is that emancipated miners cannot
vote they cannot purchase or consume
tobacco or alcohol they canot purchase
firearms why then would we allow for an
age exception for marriage and nothing
else more so emancipated miners are
among the most vulnerable of children
why then would we want to put them in a
position to be taken advantage of by
manipulative unsavory adults the bottom
line is this plain and simple children
should not be getting married and there
should be no
exception I ask that you vote itl on the
Speaker the motion before us is your
Kell floor Amendment 1455 h division has
the motion before us is you Kell floor
Amendment
1455 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative D Simone for a
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know this amendment fixes
only one of the many problems with the
underlying
Bill and Mr Speaker if I know that title
43 Domestic Relations
461 colon 461b colon 8
Roman numeral 3 emancipation of a
16-year-old minor may be granted by the
court if it is found to be in the best
interest of said minor and the minor has
demonstrated the ability and
maturity to be self-sufficient
financially and personally further Mr
Speaker if I know that once granted
emancipation the minor will be given the
right to live
independently in housing of the Minor's
choice enter into contractual
agreements consent to Medical Care
obtain legal counsel enlist in the
military and many other rights afforded
to independently living people then Mr
Speaker I would respect that a minor
would be mature enough to decide whether
decide their marital status by voting
yes and pressing the green button thank
you Mr Speaker chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that in the Last 5 Years 11 states
Connecticut Delaware Massachusetts
Michigan Minnesota New Jersey New York
Pennsylvania Rhode Island Vermont and
Washington all of which have
emancipation laws have passed
legalization legislation to end child
marriage if I also know that New
Hampshire RSA 461b states that
emancipated minors are not exempt from
age restricted laws and if I know that
the US state department has declared
child marriage a human rights violation
and we as legislators should not be
taking the stance that it is in some
instances okay to violate H child human
rights when I now press the red button
so that we can dismiss this dangerous
loophole and move on to vote for the
underlying bill that passed out the
the motion before us is the ellaa floor
Amendment 1455 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present have the opportunity
vote 169 voting a 195 voting a the
motion
failed bills on second reading open to
further Amendment repr of Kella offers
floor
Amendment
Pockets representative Mell recognize to
I understand that some people had uh
qualms with the First Amendment having
the the 16 to 18 being struck in and
that this amendment is just specifically
only uh dealing with uh emancipation and
so hopefully that that will uh alleviate
some of those qualms uh that that
Speaker setting a standard for an
marriageable age is setting a rule and
like most rules there are exceptions and
I want to talk to you about the
exception of
pregnancy in my family and my friends
have two examples of minors who got
married because of pregnancy
one son one daughter of a friend and her
boyfriend
celebrated getting engaged they were
high school sweethearts with getting
pregnant suddenly the love marriage
babies timeline is
reversed they elected to get
married because that offered to the
young woman things that she didn't have
before stability provision protection
and a chance for a young family to be a
family before a baby
arrived the goal was still the same
marriage and raising a family together
they just got there in a little
different timeline in my own
relatives a 17-year-old was uh pregnant
by a man who was older than 18 and that
was a difficult issue for our family but
in the end with cons consultation
between both parties and both families
um there was a marriage which has last
uh because we just enveloped the man and
his family into our family and it's been
that way ever
since I just want to say that I'm I'm
supporting this amendment because it
offers an
exception and it is not a rule that a
minor would be allowed to marry a person
who is going for emancipation has to
make a strong case for emancipation and
I believe that that gives enough
Safeguard to
protect marriage but also to allow that
option in cases where that would be a
good solution I urge you to support this
amendment does the member yield the
questions I yield representative leakage
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that I was 16 and Priscilla was just
barely
17 when we got married and uh it's
almost 53 years ago and we didn't need
any outside input from anyone we've been
married almost 53 years would you
believe
that yes representative I would believe
that and I would probably attribute that
to the good character and worth of the
woman you married does a
member does a member yield to further
questions yes I would sen Edwards
inquire uh thank you Mr Speaker and
thank you for taking my question um do
you do you agree with the point of view
that uh if we continually restrict the
freedom of marriage as a legitimate
social option um when we do this to
people who are of a fertile ripe fertile
age and may have may have a pregnancy
and a baby involved are we not in fact
making abortion a much more desirable
alternative when marriage might be the
couple thank you representative and I
just go back to my original illustration
in the that in some cases this offers
protection help and support for what's
going to be a young family anyways at a
time when they need it the most and
that's why I'm urging your support of
this amendment do member yield to
further
questions no member does not
yield the motion before us is the kellor
amendment
1700h are you ready for the question
oh yeah's
speaking my mistake CH recognized
GRE thank you Mr Speaker I think we all
can agree that marriage is an emotional
lifetime commitment based on love not a
solution to an unintended
pregnancy we should not be putting
children in a position to be taken
advantage of by unsavory adults
and I'll stand by my remarks earlier the
bottom line is this children should not
be getting married period there should
Speaker represent representative dry has
requested a division vote uh members
so
a motion before us is a Kell Flor
Amendment
1700h this is a division vote chair
recognizes represent of dry for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that sometimes people who are
not yet leg legally adults are thrown
into adult
situations and if I know that sometimes
the solution for this is um maybe
something that other people would not
choose uh and Mr Speaker if I wanted to
offer the option of marriage to those
who need it and want use it as a
respectable and profitable
and stability giving solution to a to a
situation that might be beyond their
control would I then please
uh
vote green on this
amendment chair recognize representative
in thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
the US state department has declared
child marriage as a human rights
violation and we as legislator should
not be taken the stance that is in some
instances okay to violate children's
human rights would I now press the red
button so we can demiss this dangerous
loophole and move on to vote for the
underlying Bill thank
you motion before us is the Kella floor
Amendment
1700h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you press the red button
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay the
vote 180 voting a 185 voting a motion
fails we're now back to the original
motion of a to pass on Senate Bill
thank you Mr
Speaker so I have a problem with a rule
with no
exceptions and I believe that I I have
had enough personal experience to know
that sometimes
exceptions can be life-changing in a
good way and I am afraid that with
passing this bill without exceptions
allowing for minors under the age of 18
to
marry this bill is
not uh
I would vote against this bill I do not
support it and I'm I believe that I
have the personal experience to justify
that but I also realized that young
people need some support sometimes it's
given by their family sometimes it's
given by marriage sometimes it's given
by both I think that they need to have
those options open when they make a
lifechanging decision so I ask you to
please defeat this bill so that we can
work on this another time thank you Mr
member yielder
questions yes I yield sen Roy your May
inquire thank you Mr speaker thank you
for taking my
questions under this bill um does it
allow for any exception at all for and
this is what I'm concerned about we we
do have teen pregnancy and we do have
people that are together in
relationships for person who who may be
in the military to marry a pregnant
teenager who may be a year younger and
he's getting shipped overseas or she's
getting sipped overseas to be able to
access the benefits from the military
the health benefits um and God forbid
something happens to him that she's
taken care of for the rest of her life
from those benefits so she's not alone
them thank you for the question and I I
I understand what you're asking I do
believe that there is some provision in
the military to do that but what happens
is you rob someone of a life changing
experience of marriage and def
definition if you do not let uh people
marry before the
military yeah so there is there is no
exception for that and I believe that if
you're old enough to go and Fight for
Your Country you're old enough to
understand what the ramifications of
that are and you also know that you need
to get married and if you want to do
that I believe that they should be able
recognize thank you Mr
Speaker for the past 10 years I have
researched child marriage I have talked
with Advocates participants victims
researchers doctors lawyers teachers
politicians and many many children
through through my research I have
learned about the devastating effects of
child marriage in the United States
children are forced to marry through
familiar deception cultural tradition
emotional blackmail threats of abuse or
even death and human trafficking child
marriage robs girls and boys of their
childhood advens their well-being girls
who married before 18 are more likely to
experience domestic violence and they
have worse economic health outcomes than
their unmarried
peers which eventually pass down to
their children girls and women in the US
who marry before 19 are 50% more likely
than their unmarried peers to drop out
of high school and four times less
likely to graduate from
college child Grooms are abused
manipulated and forced to take an adult
take on adult responsibilities for which
they may not be ready to quote article
three of the convention of the rights of
children and all actions concerning
children whether undertaken by public or
private social welfare institutions
courts of law administrative authorities
or legislative bodies the best interests
of the child shall be a primary
consideration child marriage under any
circumstance is not in the best interest
of the
child just because something has been
done for centuries does not mean we are
the same Society we grow we adapt we
change we evolve as a society and so do
our laws
please remember we are not looking to
deny children their right to marry we
are delaying their right to marry until
they become adults and can have and can
give full informed legal consent and
they can have the full legal capacity to
understand what they are getting into
before entering the contract of marriage
I urge you to vote with the majority of
the committee who voted 14
to1 and the body on the other side of
the wall who voted unanimously to pass
you pres Dres requested a division vote
the motion before us is the committee
report of autop pass on Senate Bill 359
this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that no exceptions means no
exceptions and if I know that there are
exceptions in real life and if I know
that we need to offer a choice would I
vote no uh and press the red button on
this bill chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I believe that ideally marriage is a
lifetime commitment and that children
are incapable of making such a mature
and profound
decision also be an
order and if I believe that
children who are not yet old enough to
vote purchase firearms purchase and
consume alcohol or tobacco are also not
old enough to get married and lastly Mr
Speaker if I believe that adults not
children should be getting married where
they now press the green button to vote
ought to pass thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is ought to
passes Senate Bill 359 this a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
all members presid have the opportunity
to vote also will attend to stay to the
vote
192 voting a 174 voting a committee
adopted for what reason is the member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I request that
the remarks from SB 359 be put in the
permanent journal without objection
committee on children and family law to
which was referred Senate Bill 417 FN
act relative to out of home placements
for children every consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation of Bill ought
to pass with Amendment presor Mark
Pearson for the
committee the amendment is 1587 H
printed in house record 17 Page 46 are
you ready for the question on the
say okay there's been a request for a
division on the
me
amendment
5878 chair Rec this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Mark
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh this
Amendment goes to a bill that was worked
on and uh unanimously supported the
amendment takes out a statement that
many concluded sorry if I know if if I
know that this amendment takes out a
statement that many concluded was way
too broad and could go any
direction and if I know that it takes
out a statement which while true
seem to many of us to be a little in
your
face and if I know that we added a
definition of fictive kin because the
word appears in a number of laws but it
is not defined and if I knew that the
definition that we put in there came
from a working group of people from
several States would I not push the
green button to accept the amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is Amendment
1587 H this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
[Music]
represent
all members present have the opportunity
vote 175 voting a 188 voting a the
amendment
fails question now is on art to
pass on Senate Bill 4177
FN what reason does a member rise to
make a motion of a higher priority State
your motion I move to table SP 417 and
would ask for a roll call
vote motion to table the motion is
proper for to table SE uh Senate Bill
417 FN Senate P ask for a roll call is
that sufficiently second is sufficiently
motion before us is a table Senate Bill
417 FN this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative H for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the committee
amendment was just defeated if I further
know
that if you read the current section of
law on page 46 in our
calendar it says and I quote a parent
who has not been charged with abuse or
neglect shall be afforded upon request a
chance unquote a chance to prove their
innocence in a courtroom so that they
can be a parent to their children would
I now vote no sorry yes on the tabling
motion and press the green button so
that this bill can be defeated thank you
here recogniz representative laen for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the current state
of New Hampshire Foster uh out out of
placement out of Resident placements is
uh is happening more often this bill
would help that not to happen and have
the child stay in the community uh then
when I press the uh red button on table
and this Bill thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is a table Senate Bill
417 FM this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
represent
L all members president have an
opportunity to vote also tend to State
the
vote 180 voting a 184 voting voting a to
tabling motion
fails now we're back to the original
motion of ought to
pass representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
motion before us is aut to pass on
sendable 417 FN this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your pooser press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present and an opportunity
vote 191 voting a 174 voting a committee
finance committee on children and family
law to which was referred Senate Bill
463 FN en act expanding access to court
appointed councel for children
independency proceedings consider the
same report the same with the
recommendation to Bill out of
sentive Deborah D Simone for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I I suppose nay
the eyes have it committee report is
committee on children and family law to
which was referred Senate Bill 498 FN an
act relative to Department of Health and
Human Services Division for children
youth and families having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass pres Heather Raymond for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I iose nay the
adopted the committee on children and
family law to which was referred Senate
Bill 573 FN en act establishing a
committee to study consent and
confidentiality laws applicable to
Adolescent and youth adult Health Care
in New Hampshire considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
Bill ought to pass sen a pat long for
the committee you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and committee
adopted committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
Senate Bill 248 FN an act relative to
bail for a defendant considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
Bill be referred for interim study
Senator Jennifer rhods for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I iose nay the eyes have it
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred Senate Bill
316 FN establishing a penalty for a
person who transports fanol class drugs
into New Hampshire with the intent to
recommendation for what reason is a
member rise thank you Mr Speaker to make
a motion State your motion I move to
recommit Senate Bill 316 back to the um
house criminal justice
committee like to recommit Senate Bill
36 316 back to the
committee are you ready are you ready
for the
question all those in favor say i
hios
[Applause]
division only those in the room can vote
the motion is to recommit Senate Bill
316 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
oppos you press a red button voting
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 172 voting a 180 voting a the
motion fails we're back to the original
to
pass representative jandrin moves ought
pass chair recognizes representative
Harriet
goth
David good morning Mr
Speaker good morning fellow
representative I want to be clear SP 316
is not whether there is an oport problem
in this state we all know that this
problem exists and is also not about
whether we think possessing fentol and
bringing it into the state should be
illegal it already is illegal and those
who possess and self fanol face severe
penalties available today under existing
law the question before us today is
whether we think think that adopting
mandatory minimums an outdated one-size
fitall solution is Going to Be an
Effective use of taxpayer dollars in
addressing the opor problem in our
state the bottom line is that our
country has already tried this approach
for decades through the War on Drugs
mandatory minimums used by federal
government and states to try to
incarcerate
our way out of the drug problem plaguing
our
communities and that approach failed our
country it was overly simplistic and
extremely costly to the taxpayer and our
communities and it has done nothing to
reduce drug use sales overdoses or
deaths multip multiple studies over the
past four decades have demonstrated that
mandatory minimum has not worked they do
not reduce drug use they do nothing to
Impact Drug sales or crime and they may
increase crime rates as they saw in
Florida with 50% rise in crimes after
instituting mandatory
minimums and it was the taxpayers left
holding the bill for excessive
incarceration with Rising prison and
jail populations with no reduction in
drug use sales or crimes to show for
it beyond the Practical implication
there are basic constitutional
principles at stake here mandatory
minimum sentence defeat the purpose of
sentencing by taking discretion away
from the judges and giving it to
prosecutors who use the threat of these
lengthy punishments to frustrate
defendants asserting their
constitutional rights this shift imp
power from judges to prosecutors creates
real separation of powers issues David
Kean a prominent gun rights Advocate and
advisor to George HW Bush Administration
has stated the following my opposition
to mandatory minimums is rooted in a
conservative principle namely reverence
for the Constitution and contempt for
government action that ignores the
difference amongst individuals James
Madison for one believed that a clear
separation of powers was more vital to
protecting freedom than the Bill of
Rights yet mandatory minimum undermined
the important protector of Liberty the
attempt by legislators and the Congress
to address perceived problems in the
justice system by transferring power
from judges to prosecutors and the
executive branch violate their
principles and have in the process giv
prosecutors
unreviewable authority to influence
sentences through their charging
decisions and ple bogging power and that
is what he
said as a result in this problematic
shift in power so well described by
David King the mandatory minimum
sentencing robs judges of their ability
to fully consider all relevant facts and
circumstan anwers for sentencing such as
the nature and context of particular
crime or the individual's crime
record this is why New Hampshire
currently has few mandatory minimums and
why the New Hampshire legislature has
consistently worked to remove mandatory
minimums from our statutes over the last
Des decade this is also why Advocates
from across the political Spectrum have
opposed SP
316 finally adding insult to injury
sb316 adds a new Clause expanding asset
forfeiture authority of the police the
house has been working for years to
reform and narrow the asset forfeiture
policy authority of law enforcement due
to fear of lack of due process and
unfair deprivation of property now is
not the time time to expand the
government's asset forfeiture
Authority given what we know today about
the impact of mandatory minimum
sentences the question of what to do
with SP 316 should not be a difficult
one I am asking the body to reject the
return to an outdated policy that's
proven expensive and ineffective at comb
combating drug use sales deaths and that
undermines basic principles of
Justice I urge you to vote red on the
art to pass a motion so another
appropriate motion of can be made thank
you Mr Speaker and I request a division
vote chair recognized representative
Roy thank you Mr
Speaker that's a lot to unpack all right
so mandatory minimums first of all
they're not unconstitutional they've
been around for a while we have some
here generally speaking speaking as a as
a process for criminal justice I'm not
in favor of broad mandatory minimums
either um they were used broadly during
the 80s and early 90s during the crack
epidemic um same thing with the three
strikes
rules it's not that they weren't
effective it's that broadly implemented
they they sent A lot of people to prison
who probably didn't need to
go that being
said when you strategically they can
have a very good def deter effect we had
a a gentleman here from Manchester a
former convicted um drug dealer who did
federal time during our bail
hearings and he was part of the input we
took from everyone and we asked him you
know what what do you think would would
be better deter this um and we were
talking about you know people getting
out on bail and being arrested and he
said I quote if you want to stop this
fentel problem
you need to bring back mandatory
minimums he said I'm from New York and
back when that was mandatory minimum
people refused to come to New Hampshire
because they knew we would have to go to
jail so we would go to Massachusetts
once you got rid of those now we moved
up the drugs are coming from L and
Lawrence we know that there's no
deterrent the deterrent would be if you
want to bring these drugs to New
Hampshire so that they can poison our
children
and you're caught you're going to jail
for 5 years so that's a decision you can
weigh for yourself when you get in your
car speaking of car the part about the
um asset forfeiture that was what we
were going to recommit for but the
question
was whether it's after conviction or
before conviction it's my reading of the
bill that it would be after because you
have to be convicted of actually
transporting to lose the
vehicle um interesting thing about the
Vehicles they use to transport these
they spend sometimes tens of thousands
of dollars to have these vehicles fitted
so you have to like turn on your
windshield wiper put on your right
blinker and tune the radio to 92.4 FM so
a hide opens up where all the drugs are
hidden it's not just you know the family
vehicle they're
using that being said we've with the
with regard to the expense I've heard
numbers around 56 something a thousand a
year to incarcerate somebody it costs
well over $100,000 a year to have
someone in and out of rehab a couple
times and the associated medical bills
much more than the cost of
incarceration but that being said we're
targeting here not the user Who We R we
spend Millions every year to help people
who are addicted to these
drugs but at the same time we can't just
keep treating the symptom we have to
treat the underlying cause so we
continue and we should continue helping
people who are addicted to drugs but at
some point we have to take steps to stop
the poison from coming in in the first
place otherwise we'll just keep pouring
more money more money and digging more
Graves and more Graves now it is true
that deaths have gone down but that's
only because we have sent more Naran out
into the society so people are being
brought back so they can overdose again
the drug epidemic has not gone away
people are still being addicted they're
still overdosing in record numbers
they're just more of them surviving the
overdose so it's true these were tried
before and in my opinion and studies and
the numbers show they did stop the crack
epidemic Unfortunately they caught up a
lot of people that they shouldn't have
because it those minimum mandatories
were much much broader if you got caught
with any amount of a drug you could be
sented for for years years this is
simply anyone caught coming over our
border with the intent to poison our
children would have to make a choice
when they decided to take that ride is
it worth five years of your life to come
up here and poison our children if you
decide to take that risk that's on you
no one made you do it so I would
encourage you to think about that how
much money we spend on everything risk
reward do we want to put some type of
penalty to deter these people from doing
these acts thank you does the member
yield the
questions no member does not
yield s goth is requested a division
C
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill
316 this is a division vote chair
recognizes senate musees for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you
colleagues Mr Speaker if I know that
multiple studies over the last four
Decades of our failed War on Drugs show
that mandatory minimum penalty do
nothing to reduce crime drug sales drug
arrests or overdose rates and if I know
that long mandatory prison sentences
increase both the cost of incarceration
and the chances of reism once the
offender has been released and if I know
our current statute gives judges
discretion to sentence offenders for
this crime to up to 30 years in prison
for transporting drugs with intent to
distribute and they often do and finally
if I know that our state does not have a
Judicial discretion program uh problem
but that it does have a fenel problem
that requires thoughtful evidence-based
policy solutions for the 2020s rather
than failed policy solutions from the
1980s then would I press the red button
so another motion can be made thank you
chair recogniz representative rhs for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire needs to
address the C cause of a person's
addiction and not just the effect and by
passing this spill we will be addressing
this issue from all
angles and if I know there is no better
example of unfair deprivation than a
loved one grieving a family member that
is dead and Mr Speaker if I know the
excuse of the price of incarceration is
irrelevant considering you can't com you
can't put a price on a person's life
would I now press green with the
committee motion before us is ought to
pass on senat Bel 316 they say division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
representative
testerman all members present had an
opportunity to vote also tend to stay
fails
got representative goth moves
inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those
May the eyes have it any inexpedient to
is committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety which was referred Senate
Bill
376 relative to establishing a
Corrections education and vocational
Planning Group this comes without
represent without
recommendation sentive new rules ought
to pass the chair recognized
representative
rhs thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker at first glance this
study committee does seem like it would
be a really good
idea they want to use pel grants and
they want to use funding from the let me
see what it is the Alliance Group to
further educate at people while they're
in prison and we did learn in the
committee that there are educational
opportunities available and there are
many people that are incarcerated to
take advantage of the opportunities that
are available but as we took a deeper
dive into this I started asking some
questions
and I asked about would it matter how
long a person's incarceration was and I
was told no it wouldn't matter so if a
person is serving a life
sentence same rules would apply however
they also said well we would probably
put them further down on the list so
they're kind of building this airplane
while we're trying to fly it the other
thing we have to consider
is what happens whenever this money runs
out so is a person I consider to be a
friend that's in our committee actually
said and I don't mean to pick on her but
you know I'm going to have to here she
said well it's not going to cost us
anything it's free money from the
government all right there you have it
so additionally
I don't think it's very good Steward of
our tax dollars so when you make this
decision think about this do you really
want to pay for Adam Montgomery to get a
college education I know that I don't
constituents chair recognized
thank you Mr
Speaker hello my distinguished
colleagues the bill before us today is a
fairly straightforward proposal SP 376
seeks to establish a Planning Group
composed of relevant stakeholders and
experts for the purpose of determining
the best uh possible method of
facilitating successful reintegration
into society through educational
programs for incarcerated
individuals there are federal funds
available to cover this uh expense
incarcerated individuals have access to
many of the same financing mechanis
mechanisms that those of us on the
outside do largely pel grants that are
granted to the individual by the federal
government so we are not asking for
funding nor are we asking for the
educational programs themselves in this
bill we are simply asking in seeking to
convene a group to consider all the
relevant factors that would lead to the
best outcome for those incarcerated and
for Society at large the research is
very clear those incarcerated
individuals who re-enter Society with
vocational opportunities are much less
likely to reoffend with proper planning
and careful implementation we can reduce
recidivism increase Public Safety and
save the taxpayers a pretty penny while
we're at it fun fundamentally we are
asking you to facilitate good
stewardship of the resources at our
disposal I would hope that this body
could agree that thoughtful
consideration and planning uh is in all
of our best interest and please join me
in passing this Bill thank
you Representative no has requested a
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 376 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative Reed for
thank you Mr Speaker members of the
house to summarize what representative
roads if I know um what representative
roads stated um people incarcerated
currently incarcerated in New Hampshire
do have the ability to take college
credit
courses and if I know that um these um
courses will be funded by uh grants and
private monies once those dry up the
taxpayers will be responsible for
funding free education for the
incarcerated lastly if I know that
incarceration should not be a pathway to
a free college education would I now
vote o um itl on SB
376 chair recognize rep Senate mes for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
goal of our correction system isn't to
create better criminals but to create
better citizens who upon their release
are committed to being crime-free and
capable of being
self-supporting and if I know New
Hampshire businesses facing labor
shortages are looking at apprenticeships
and work experiences for incarcerated
persons and there are emerging synergies
between uh what employers are looking
for and the coursework that's offered by
our community college system and finally
if I know that incarcerated individuals
who participate in educational
programming are 48% less likely to
return to prison within 3 years of
release than those who don't participate
then would I press the green button to
support a bill that has the enthusiastic
support of both our department of
corrections and our community college
system and has available funding from
the federal government thank
you motion before us is a to pass on
Senate Bill 376 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
represent
Sim if all members present have an
opportunity to vote also ATT to stay to
the
vote 192 voting a 170 voting a committee
next one
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which is referred Senate Bill
414 FN relative establishing a mandatory
minimum sentence for the crime
distribution of a controlled duck with
death resulting comes without
recommendation senat Stone moves are to
pass for what reason does the member
rise make a motion State your motion I
move to lay house uh Senate Bill 414 on
the table that is a priority motion the
motion before us is to table Senate Bill
ready yeah you want a division a
division has been request a division has
yes
the motion before us is to table Senate
Bill 414 this is a division vote chair
recognizing representative Roy for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that the body just
voted against uh M mandatory minimum of
five years by like 120 something votes
and I don't really relish trying to sell
them on 10 years would I then vote to
kill this bill so we can move on to
other stuff that we do want to talk
about chair recognize represent will for
a parliamentary inquiry Mr Speaker if I
know that the table should be used for
tabling bills and not kill them would I
then vote against the tabling motion so
another motion can be
made the motion before us is to table
Senate Bill
414 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
your opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
[Music]
Thomas all members pres an opportunity
vote 340 voting a 24 voting a Senate
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred Senate Bill
415 FN act relative to penalty for
certain fentanyl related
offenses considered the same report the
same with the recommendation the bill be
referred for interim study sen Jennifer
rhods for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay the eyes have it
and Senate Bill 415 is referred for
the majority of committee on criminal
justice of Public Safety to which was
referred Senate Bill 563 FN act relative
to Fed Federal immigration enforcement
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
committee minority of the committee I
consider the same being unable to agree
with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
committee
uh for what reason to the member rise Mr
Speaker I move to lay this on the
table that is a priority motion the
motion
is the motion is in
order and a division has been requested
representative swe asked for aoll call
Representative Sweeney has asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
vote says I want to kill the says I want
the most motion before us is to lay
order is to lay Senate Bill 563 FN on
the table chair recognized
representative wheeler for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
legislating should be done through due
process and deliberative bills and we
should not be voting on amendments that
we got just beforehand both in committee
and on the floor and Mr Speaker if I
know that this legislation puts due
process concerns into law and there
needs to be more work on this bill would
I then move to have this bill laid onto
the table thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Roy for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I was going to say
that tabling motions should not be used
bills but I noticed that didn't work
very
well would I then suggest that we see
the amendment hear the amendment
see if it improves the bill and would I
then let the body continue to debate
this very serious issue that both sides
would like to be heard on thank
you the motion before us is to table
Senate Bill 563 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if they oppos you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 188 voting a 177 voting a Senate
table committee on education to which
order we're going to be taking our lunch
at
12:30 committee on education to which
was referred Senate Bill 219 FN
requiring mandatory reporting by school
districts School expenses it comes
without
recommendation representative Alicia
leakas moves ought to pass chair
cascaden thank you Mr Speaker as an
experienced School administrator I know
how School budgets are developed I know
how they're prepared for the public and
for the local legislative bodies for
approval or disapproval all school
districts in New Hampshire must follow
Municipal budget law and are required to
submit all School District expend to the
New Hampshire Department of
Education Municipal budget Law requires
the district to print its budget in an
annual report and make it available to
the public the law further States the
disclosure of purpose and amounts must
be expressed at hearings including the
subac account
information who votes to approve or
disapprove local school district budgets
you
do all public school expenditures must
be submitted in a format known as the
doe2 annual report the doe 25 lists all
School expenditures for instruction and
for Support Services which include
operation and maintenance of buildings
cost per puple is based on current
expenditures as reported on each School
District's annual financial report cost
per pupil represents current
expenditures less tuition and
transportation cost
further public access to all the details
of school expenditures is available in
three easy clicks New Hampshire
Department of Education
website click on data
reports click public
reports any town city or school district
office can easily provide this
information for any constituent who
can't find it or who doesn't participate
in their local budget process
Senate Bill 219 as written Compares New
Hampshire with Massachusetts for
teaching staff the bill further States
lowest teacher salaries with highest
administrative costs which aren't
comparable nor have any bearing on the
title of the
bill these data points have no citations
where they come from how are they
comparable to individual New Hampshire
districts School District Administrative
structure and organization may be the UN
underlying intent the bill title does
not state that this bill appears to
request School expenditures be made
available to the
public the sponsors of the bill based on
its parts appear to identify the size
and wealth of Education bureaucracy as a
state
problem as a property taxpayer myself a
very valid concern in our individual
districts this is not a Statewide
problem that needs state government to
overreach our locally controlled
communities it's up to the local voters
and the elected officials to set their
school budgets decide their structure
and
organization and determine the cost
factors necessary to offer a public
education that meets all the
requirements of the New Hampshire laws
if wealthier towns desire highly paid
administrators and well-paid teachers
they have that option and choice but in
New Hampshire the real ity for many is
that property poor communities do not
have that option if this bill is
submitted because a person couldn't find
local information then why not seek to
ask local
governance if the information SS
difficult to find then that's a local
issue local control means towns cities
and school districts make decisions
locally including following all parts of
the municipal budget law in RSA 198 cone
4-g civil re remedies are sought with
this bill what does that mean if I can't
find a report on local school
expenditures I can file a
lawsuit and that I'm owed relief that a
school district will incur additional
legal expenditures and have to increase
their school
budgets please vote no on OTP so that
Noble thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues over the last two
decades our cost per pupil in New
Hampshire has gone up
77% when adjusted for
inflation when looking at teacher
salaries there has been minimal increase
in comparison to the sharp rise in per
pupil cost in fact according to reaching
higher New Hampshire teachers are
actually making 8% less than they were
in
2019 when adjusted for
inflation Massachusetts is spending
roughly the same amount as us at about
20,000 per student but somehow the
average salary of a New Hampshire
teacher is almost 20,000 less than the
average salary of a teacher in
Massachusetts if the data from m
Massachusetts tells us anything it is
that our teacher pay crisis has nothing
to do with our taxes and spending being
too low over the past 20 years
non-teaching staff has gone up 80% and
that growth in administration includes
assistant
superintendents and full-time diversity
Professionals in the same period we
increased the number of teachers by
23% as of this year some administrators
are making three times the average
salary of a New Hampshire
teacher these are just the facts if we
want taxpayers to continue to invest in
their local schools they need to know
where that money is being spent and how
that investment Trends over
time this bill would provide that
transparency in a clear and accessible
format with three very simple line
graphs and one
table the line graphs will show average
cost per pupil average teacher salary
and administrator
salaries and how they Trend over the
previous 10 years the table will display
the top four administrator salaries and
their
titles the average taxpayer doesn't know
how to find this information they
shouldn't have to go digging on the
district or doe websites to piece the
data
together just as you would get charts
and graphs for any personal fund that
you invest in taxpayers should be given
the data about their
investment this bill would ensure
transparency for all stakeholders to
make more informed decisions during the
budget
process this is not a burden on our
school districts they have all the the
data and are more than capable of
producing these three simple line graphs
and one forline
table all taxpayers have a vested
interest in the academic success of New
Hampshire students as well as our
ability to retain teachers this bill
would provide for transparency and help
our local communities to rep prioritize
spending if necessary while putting the
needs of students and their hardworking
teachers first I urge you to vote green
thank you and Mr Speaker I request a
vote Noble has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is how to pass on
Senate Bill 219 this is a roll call vote
chair recogniz rep of B Bon for a
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know to paraphrase Mark
Twain that there are lies darn lies and
statistics and this bill skewed D data
to imply that public schools are short
changing
students and I know that this
information is already available and
posted on the Department of Education
website and additional financial
information required by law must be made
publicly available by school districts
already finally if I know that it is the
responsibility of the locally elected
school boards to respond to taxpayer
concerns and these school board members
can be voted out if taxpayers are
dissatisfied with their
stewardship then would I now press the
red button to keep financial reporting
decisions at the local level and allow
another motion to be
made chair recognize representative
Celli for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this is about
accountability and transparency not
lies if I know that this bill will
provide information on school budgets to
the public before the school board votes
on the budget
and if I know that teachers might be
very interested in their salary as
compared to the growing number of
Administrators and their salaries would
I now vote for transparency and support
button the motion before us is ought to
pass in Senate Bill 219 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
repres
all members present on an opportunity to
vote 180 voting yay 179 voting nay and
committee on education to which was
referred Senate Bill 341 relative to
mandatory Disclosure by School District
employees to parents this comes without
recommendation Senate beler moves ought
to
pass and the amendment is 15898 printed
in house record 17 Page 39 are you ready
for the question on the amendment all
n a division has been requested members
take your members only in the chamber
in the question is on the
amendment if you're in favor you will
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
while members presentent had an
opportunity to vote I will attend to
vote 179 voting aay 182 voting nay the
amendment fails for what reason the
member rise move inde definite
postponement of Senate Bill 341 and I
vote representative Wilhelm
moves definite
postponement for and ask for a roll call
what what do you want what do you want
to
the motion before us
is indefinite postponement on Senate
Bill 341 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Damon for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning colleagues if I know the New
Hampshire Department of Education stated
that the bill language in s SP 341 is
unclear subjective and would be very
difficult to enforce and the office of
the child advocate said the bill quote
threatens the health safety and
intrinsic rights of Granite State
residents if I know that parents and
Educators routinely collaborate and
share on behalf of students well-being
if I know this unnecessary Bill
endangers vulnerable youth while
violating their constitutional right to
privacy and if I know that a basic
premise of our work together is to keep
all children safe would I now press the
green button to indefinitely postpone
thank
you chair recognized represent of
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that parental rights continue to be
breached across this country if I
believe that parents are the ultimate
decision makers when it comes to their
children and if I know the Supreme Court
has repeatedly validated fundamental
parent rights would I then press the red
button so we can restore and protect the
fundamental rights of
parents the motion before us is in depth
postponement on Senate Bill 341 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
oppose you press the red button voting
representative
M while members present had an
opportunity to vote also tend to stay
185 voting a 106 voting a Senate Bill
that we've got two announcements uh
chair recognized representative
thank you for your attention this is d
uh the granted Bridge legislative
Alliance is having two upcoming events
one on Monday is a workshop at the up
and Walker house and you can get mileage
for attending and it's to learn to deal
across the aisle essentially to listen
and be respectful with each other and uh
come away with it it recognize that if
somebody disagrees with you it doesn't
make them enemies uh but it's that will
be Monday we're a few short of
Republicans we get more Democrats than
Republicans so I want to recruit one my
Republican friends the other event is on
uh May 11th we have a Fisher Cats game
coming up and if anybody's interested in
that talk with representative Corman
thank
you I can't say it better than
representative PL so uh please join us
on one of these occasions we would love
to have you thanks so much chair
lad thank you very much Mr Speaker uh as
a reminder on page 36 of your calendar
this afternoon if we get out of here by
4 o' which doesn't look too good um
there is a screening uh down at the Red
River Theaters in conquered regarding a
film which has been put up by Kean
Plymouth State and UNH of how those
institutions are impacting our state
right now all are invited uh poporn
drinks and light Fair will be served
thank
you we got one more thing to do so
please return to your seats chair
mononi thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
be recogniz for a motion State your
motion um I would ask to special order
Senate Bill 592 from Public Works which
is a renaming a section of roadway in
Franklin to uh honor Chief hos to uh
week you you recognize to speak to your
motion if you have anything else or was
that pretty much it thank you uh we in
inadvertently had two naming bills on
the calendar and um family member of
Chief hos was not able to be here this
week but will be available to be in the
Indulgence the motion is the special
order of Senate Bill 592 until next week
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I oppose nay no the eyes
have it
1:30
e
recognizes the clerk for reports thank
you Mr Speaker the committee on enrolled
bills has examined and found correctly
enrolled the following entitled House
and Senate bills House Bill 261 558 1,4
1,88 1154 Senate Bill 313 Senate Bill
322 Senate Bill 363 Senate Bill 470
566 the house will come to order like to
point the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred Senate
Bill 596 FN an act relative to the
definition of disability or special
needs under the child care scholarship
program having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative hope Damon for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative Mike belshire for
committee find your
seats please settle down so that we can
hear the people who will be speaking
right now representative vure is
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr chair good afternoon
colleagues it is my pleasure to get to
speak to you immediately after
speaker now I would like you to keep in
mind because the topic of this bill
addresses the uh the definition of of a
disabled person a Disabled Student in
education so I I want you to keep in
mind as I discussed that that as of
right now more than 25% of New Hampshire
Public School students are recognized as
disabled for purposes of either
receiving accommodation or treatment or
an
IEP over one in
four now what this bill would do is it
significantly expands the definition of
disability for uh especially young
now it expands it so far that there is
no need to actually have a disability
there is only the need to have a
disability okay so literally any child
could theoretically be considered
disabled under this definition resulting
in a possible expansion of this
definition to who knows how many
children in this environment another
thing it does is it makes it unnecessary
to have any formal diag diagnosis for
the
child no formal diagnosis
required so what this is actually doing
is it's placing the diagnosing and
treatment and IEP and all of that stuff
it's taking that away from the
professional clinicians the Physicians
instead now these are pretty significant
problems that exist in this bill and
it's not just because it's what I've
told you so far but also because in this
particular program special education
funds are
limited and what that means is as you
expand the number of children that are
going to receive services to those who
no don't have a diagnosis and may not
need those Services you're actually
taking those Services away from other
them last special education services are
not in themselves necessarily
harmless inter interventions treatments
and accommodations introduce something
called
iatrogenesis in patients and children
who do not have a developmental disorder
who not have a problem it will actually
it has a chance of setting them on a
very bad path down a road to
medicalization and otherwise worse
outcomes now we heard that there may be
an issue that exists when it comes to
daycare services when it comes to
funding and whether or not certain
students are able to get them that's
possible it is possible we didn't get to
nail that down in committee though and
if that is a real thing and it needs to
First be established that it is a real
thing then this needs to be far more
narrowly tailored to meet the actual
needs of those students that have the
needs as it stands uh this is unworkable
so I would ask you to vote against the
OTP motion that another motion can be
made thank
you representative Damon recognized to
it thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues I hope everybody enjoyed
lunch SB 596 is a strongly bipartisan
bill that addresses the problem of
affordable child care for high need
children who do not yet have a formal
disability diagnosis but require more
Staffing to meet their needs it is well
known that New Hampshire fath es a
critical shortage of child care this
shortage has extensive adverse effects
on our businesses who need parents as
employees and on the economics of
hardworking families who need affordable
reliable child care that is appropriate
to their child's needs New Hampshire
Child Care Centers lack the resources to
provide dedicated staff for children
with additional developmental and
behavioral needs because of this many
centers have been forced to enroll fewer
children children in classrooms with
high needs children thus exacerbating
the overall Child Care availability
crisis under the existing New Hampshire
Child Care scholarship program
differential payments of $100 per week
are only available to children with
formally diagnosed disabilities or who
have identified special education
services for families at or below 85% of
State median
income SP 596 as ask the Department of
Health and Human Services to adopt rules
that will make those differential
payments available for children who are
at risk of delayed social or emotional
development please note that in this
context at risk is a clinical term with
clear meaning it is not a vague broad
statement that envelops all
children these are children who are very
likely to later receive formal
disability diagnosis but need higher
Staffing while the DI agnostic process
is
completed any licensed child care
provider who participates in the New
Hampshire childcare scholarship program
would be eligible to enroll these
children and receive the differential
payments this includes licensed Home
Care faith-based Centers privately owned
and nonprofit Child Care Centers any
licensed Center currently child care
providers are faced with the difficult
decision of either excl including these
children reducing enrollments or
charging families more money families
have difficulty finding child care and
some have been asked to leave their
child care provider because of their
child's higher needs this creates
devastating instability for families and
uncertainty for employers who need
Reliable
Staffing standard best practice in child
care already includes regular
developmental and behavioral screenings
of infants and Todd
by licensed professionals early
identification of Developmental delays
in young children allows for timely
intervention coordination of treatment
and support and improves long-term
outcomes in fact it allows many children
to catch up to their peers
developmentally by the time they reach
school age this results in cost Savings
in public schools as fewer children will
need special education services there is
no risk to any children from this
program the bill appropriates or
proposes to appropriate
$375,000 for fisol year 25 to come from
any remaining arpa funds or other
federal funds and it allows for
suspending implementation if sufficient
Federal appropriation is not
available s SP 596 offers an equitable
coste effective straightforward solution
to an urgent problem in our child care
system
it will allow our licensed child care
providers to safely maximize enrollment
I urge you to join me in voting ought to
you the questions on the majority
committee report of to pass represion
cordelli has Rec representative cordelli
has requested a division vote this will
seats
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass on Senate
Bill 5 96 this is a division vote
representative cordelli is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know there is a
question regarding what this bill is
actually seeking to achieve and maybe I
should have asked the driver of that box
truck out on Main Street that's
advertising support for this bill if I
also know that this bill modifies the de
definition of disability or special
needs to include any child
who displays or is at risk for delayed
development if I also know that the
committee did not have the necessary
time to delve into all these technical
aspects of the bill would I now press
the red button so the motion of interim
study can be brought
forward representative Halls recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the intent of this bill is to direct the
DHHS to adopt eligibility rules for the
child care scholarship program to
include young children who are not
formally identified as special needs yet
who are at risk of delayed social or
emotional development and Mr Speaker if
I know that under this Child Care
Program scholarships are provided to
eligible low-income families who access
child care in a variety of licensed
settings including the home faith-based
or Child Care Centers and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that SB 596 would
allow for differential payments of $100
a week to be paid to child care
providers who care for lowincome
children who are not formally identified
yet who are at risks for experiencing
developmental delays would I now press
the green button to take a positive step
forward in addressing early intervention
and child care availability and
affordability especially for at risk
children thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report of about to pass on
Senate Bill 596 it's a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the yes oh sorry oh you didn't
check in
no anybody else all right the houseen of
last
call the house will attends to the state
of the
vote 190 in the affirmative 170 in the
Senate Bill 596 is referred to the
finance for what reason does the member
rise thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
earlier today our friend from Hudson
gave a wonderful eulogy for a good
friend of this house and the other body
in a longtime public servant and I would
move that his remarks be placed in the
permanent
journal the motion is to print the
eulogy remarks and the permanent journal
without
objection what reason does this member
rise to make a motion State your motion
uh I'd like to motion to allow the
gentleman to remove their jackets it's
here she moves that member male members
jackets oh without objection members
members May remove their jackets for
what reason does this member rise
unpopular thank you Mr Speaker I move
that the remarks from the debate on
Senate Bill 316 be placed in the
permanent Journal Senate bill which
Senate Bill
the committee on Election law to which
is referred Senate Bill 489 FB an act
relative to election audits having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Ross Berry for
the committee questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass you
ready for the question all those in
so what happened was the bills weren't
in
order the committee on Election law to
which was referred Senate Bill 380
relative to moving the state primary
comes to us without
recommendation representative Barry
moves off to
pass represent representative bom has
motion thank you Mr
Speaker I am here to speak against the
OTP on sb380 again to speak against this
bill in January just a few months ago we
and this house voted 281 to 82 to move
the primary to the third Tuesday in
August that's a 70% vote vot it is
sitting in the other
chamber now we have a bill to move the
primary to June the second Tuesday in
June during the busiest time of the
school year remember most elections are
done in schools and the filing period
for this bill takes place in March the
first Wednesday Friday the week after in
the middle of this filing period a town
and School District
elections the town clerk is busy with
these elections and at the polls and
then have to do state filings the
secretary state is also busy with State
and County filings I guess the sponsor
of this bill didn't realize that and why
do you think that City elections are
done in the odd year so not having the
interference of State elections now we
are asked to vote for a bill that
interferes with Town elections and for
towns that have elections in
April that will be the most interference
how can people running for local office
Town Council budget committee
Schoolboard Etc compete with people
running for state county and federal
office how many campaign signs for local
office be overrun by sign for state
federal and county offices they won't be
seen for example Barac has State eight
State grips so that's more than eight
signs because it'd be Bor than double I
guess this wasn't thought of either
again we voted by 70% to have the
primary in August which is also
recommended by the Secretary of State
and that number is enough to override
any veto this bill should be lawed now
but the other body has refused to vote
for it I was elected by the people in my
town to represent them and the people of
New Hampshire we were not elected to be
puppets of some National
Organization represent B puppet was just
a step too far you may continue say good
puppets that was a little too far okay
apologize and Mr Speaker I ask for a
division vote and also ask that we not
second any motion for a roll call we do
not need any more reprisals for people
voting what is best for the state so
please join me by voting red so a proper
motion can be made we remember again we
said August a few months ago vote red
thank
you representative Brennan's recognized
motion she waves off representative
Barry's recognized to speak in support
motion thank you Mr Speaker uh one of
these days somebody's going to have to
tell me why election law is always the
bill for print remarks and pulling
things off the table but um that's just
my it's just a grievance I've wanted to
get off my chest for some time maybe
it's because we're always after lunch um
this bill moves the state primary to
June um little history on this I have
voted for August I have voted for June I
bet you if I pulled this entire room and
I said hey do you like a 45-day general
election window in September I would
venture to say 80% of you would agree
with me that September is horrible we
just can't seem to agree on what's
better August or June um I am of the
mentality of please God move it please
God move it I have voted for both of
them here's the political reality the
political reality is that August meets a
veto pen it just is once again I voted
for August this body a last term voted
for June the Senate is going to send us
back June it's June if you want to end
this Madness this 45 Day Madness you
have to vote for June trust me I
wouldn't mind August once again I have
voted for it you can always find an
excuse not to do something there is no
ideal place to put this where it doesn't
step on something it just is June I
think June's great it's going be right
at the end of school we'll be able to a
lot of place will'll be able to use the
schools but right now what we have is
what's referred to as the incumbent
protection plan I've talked about it in
this body for a long time I know I'm
talking to a room full of incumbents
saying hey you should give up your
incumbent protection but that is what's
best for the state that is what's best
for the state voters deserve to hear
from both candidates we need to unrig
question the questions on
the motion about to pass on Senate Bill
380 representative Lane request a
division vote this will be a division
all right the motion is out to pass on
Senate Bill 380 and this is a division
vote representative Brennan's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the majority of municipalities
in New Hampshire operate under the much
celebrated traditional town meeting form
of govern government and the majority of
towns hold their town meeting elections
in March with the filing period in
January and if I know that this bill
would move the primary to June which
would make the state election filing
period move to
March when this body is in the middle of
its legislative
work and if I know that moving the state
primary to June does not take into
account the real world impact on downb
valot candidates like State
reps and if I know the secretary of
state is against this bill and concerns
have been raised about recruiting
election volunteers to work our safe
secure and efficient elections all year
long Mr Speaker if I know moving the
state primary to June will create
nonstop yearr round elections to the
dismay of our con consents who already
face campaign burnout and don't want
nonstop political ads mail phone calls
yard signs everywhere all year long
would I now press the red button so a
better motion may be made thank
you representative Barry's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry and members
are reminded that you're planted in your
seats when we're in the voting mode it's
not a new rule thank thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that I have seen eight
election ads today including three yard
signs on my drivein for a primary not
until September and Mr Speaker if I know
that I believe in my colleagues that
they can walk and chew gum at the same
time then would I Mr Speaker would I
press the green button to end the
incumbent protection plan and move New
calendar the questions on the motion
about to pass Senate Bill 380 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
[Music]
well I'm almost afraid to ask but have
all members present had an opportunity
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend of the state
of the
vote 170 in the affirmative 196 in the
negative the motion
fails representative bone moves in
expedience to legislate you ready for
the Okie do representative veral request
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is members remain on your
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on Senate Bill 380 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote
success the house will attend to the
state of the
vote 190 in the affirmative 176 in a
negative the motion is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just a quick uh reminder that if
you had previously called to say that
you were going to be late or that you
were not going to be here today you need
to check in because your voting station
Speaker speak the committee on Election
law to which is referred Senate Bill 489
FN an act relative to El hi for what
reason to let me finish reading this an
act relative to election audits having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation at the bill out to
pass representative Rasberry for the
committee for what reason does the
member rise
I wanted to make a motion for indefinite
prop
prop I couldn't even motion's not in
order so we're on Senate Bill
FN there we go and the motion is ought
to pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos nay
adopted the committee on executive
departments and administration who
wishers referred Senate Bill 134 FN an
act relative to disability pensions for
Public Safety employees who are victims
of violence having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
at the bill ought to pass representative
Peter Schmidt for the committee
questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass ready for the
question all those favor say I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
say
what Senate belill 134 FN was is
referred to the committee on
Finance for what reason does a member
rise make a motion State your motion
having voted in the in the affirmative
I'd like to move to reconsider House
Bill 3 Senate Bill
380 representative bomes moves
reconsideration on Senate Bill
380 are you ready for the
question division votes been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your
the question is whether to reconsider
Senate Bill 380 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
repr
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house of attend to the state of
the
vote 191 in the affirmative 175 in the
negative the motion passes for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker I
move to table a SP
380 representative Sweeney moves the
Senate Bill 380 be laid on the table are
you ready for the question division
thought so this will be a division vote
was
the motion is to lay Senate Bill 380 on
the table if you are in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend of the state of
the
vote 175 in the affirmative 192 in the
negative the motion fails for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker I
move indefinite postponement on Senate
Bill 380 representative Weber moves to
380 hold up representative Sweeney is
recognized to speak against the motion
this a debatable motion thank you Mr
Speaker I thought we'd all benefit from
just taking a deep breath on this bill
before we vote on this motion that no
seriously that's being rushed we voted
ought to pass that didn't work somebody
moved to inexpedient to legislate that
passed so the bill was killed this is
already a conversation that we are
having the discussion and the debate
with the body on the other side why
would we indefinitely postpone an active
debate I know a thing or two about indef
itely postponing legislation why would
we indefinitely postpone a policy
subject that is actively being debated
with the other side of the wall unless
we are afraid to engage in that debate
with them on a policy change between
August and June member will suspend that
was kind of motive speak there we don't
allow that I apologize for my
indiscretion but vote red against the
indefinite postponement I would then go
along with you on inexpedient to
legislate this second week in June
primary Bill and then we can allow the
conversations with the other body to
much representative Weber's recognized
to speak in support of the motion I
am thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I have looked at the votes as
we've gone through them and I won't list
them again for you and if I
believe that it would be better to
indefinitely
postpone because
otherwise they that we should not
mention might tack this bill which most
of us don't seem to want to a bill that
this body very much wants thus leaving
us in a terrible quandry about which
policy we're going to deal with would I
now vote
red a green sorry green green
green house will be in order would I now
postponement there have been so many
useful parliamentary inquiries this term
where the member really needed the
for what reason does the member
rise question of the chair yeah would
this motion have any effect on our
ability to enroll a house bill that is
currently with the body on the other
you
okay the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone Senate Bill 380
who requested the roll
call Representative Barry requested the
roll call and it is sufficiently
seconded I don't think it was you but
this will be a roll call vote members
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone Senate Bill 380 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
[Music]
all remember M present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 178 in the
postponed majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred Senate Bill 439 FN an
act relative to prohibit discriminatory
boycotts of Israel and state
procurements and Investments having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Carol Maguire for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having consider the
same in being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Carol Brown for the
minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislated you ready for the question
all those favor say I I all those oppose
adopted the committee on executive
departments and administration which is
referred Senate Bill 487 FN an acts
relative to the division of Personnel in
the department of administrative
services having consider the same report
the same with the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass representative
Jackie groa for the committee questions
on the majority report of a to pass you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those opposed nay the
adopted Senate Bill 487 is referred to
committee on Health and Human Services
andly Affairs to which was referred
Senate Bill 352 FNA an act establishing
an early detection cancer screening
pilot program for active and retired
firefighters having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
to Bill ought to pass representative
Erica lay on for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no yes guys have it committee report
finance committee on Health and Human
Services and Eld F to which was referred
Senate Bill 355 FN relative to newborn
screening
for cpto
Meo
virus I'm sure I butchered that one up
uh representative Weber moves o to pass
and representative Lon offers floor
Amendment
1720 and is recognized to speak to her
amendment is in your seat
Pockets thank you Mr Speaker I'm not
sure how many of you have heard of cyto
megala virus um we call it CMV because
it's a lot easier to understand that
it's actually a pretty common infection
but if a woman gets it when she's
pregnant and then passes it to her baby
in some of the kids that are born with
it it can have some pretty bad outcomes
however those bad outcomes are primarily
in those infants who are born with
infant hearing loss because of CMV so if
we were to take those kids who fail
their hearing test and then screen them
for CMV we'd be able to give them well
the doctors would be able to give them
an antiviral that would reverse that
hearing loss and also May re reverse
some developmental disabilities that
come with this infection that you they
get um during this whole this whole
process so this is a specific area to
identify children who are at specific
risk and there is an intervention that
works to restore their hearing and give
them a chance to um to have a life that
might be a little bit easy year and deal
with an infection early on as we were
dealing with this in our committee and
as they dealt with it initially in the
other body it's pretty complex
especially because the hearing test that
we do for newborns isn't actually
required um it's a voluntary one that
most people do it's a really good idea
because it's good to know if your baby
can't hear so you can start intervention
and looking into the process really the
only way to make sure that doctors know
about this CMB test or that that they
know about the need to test for CMV if a
baby has failed both hearing tests is
just to put it on the form that they
fill out if the hearing test is already
happen doing that's why we have uh this
nice little floor amendment that would
direct them to change a current
administrative rule um really this is
the only way we could find to address
this issue um this is moving on to
another on to finance if we pass it
today so if there's any further
refinements I know it's not great to
work policy there but we can make
refinements later um but I think that
this is pretty key because of the 10 to
15 kids that are born in New Hampshire
with CMV related hearing loss each year
we need to make sure that those kids can
be tested and can be treated while it's
still reversible so with that I would
ask for your support on this amendment
and then on the bill with the amendment
the question before us is the lay on
floor Amendment 1720 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it in the four
Amendment it passes the motion before it
now is are the pass as amended are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it Comm report is adopted and it's
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred Senate Bill 403 FN relative to
healthc care Workforce this comes
without recommendation representative
wber moves ought to
pass the amendment is 1533 H printed in
house record 17 Page
4243 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay no the eyes have it the
amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended the chair
kofalt thank you Mr Speaker so
Senate Bill 403 is called relative to
the Health Care
Workforce it aims among other things to
alleviate the workforce uh uh shortage
in in in healthcare in New
Hampshire but one of the major
provisions of the bill is that it
creates something a a certification for
something called a community health
worker um now this position already
exists in uh in a number of places but
there is no current certification by the
state community health workers
responsibilities as they currently exist
overlap substantially with those of
social workers case managers and skilled
nursing
staff there are a couple of major issues
with this bill number one certification
is
optional so let's say that you become a
certified health work uh Community
Health
worker and you get caught doing
something thing you shouldn't be doing
and you lose your certification for
cause can you still be a community
health worker the answer is
yes why then would we create this
certification
well I'm not sure what the answer is to
that but I I will say that there's quite
a lot of um quite a lot of money
involved and there would be some
additional State spending
um the the fiscal note explains that
this is uh will cost
$4,650 in year
one um if you look a little further down
on the page you see 4.2
million that's because this creates a
broad new um entitlement under
Medicaid and what we're really doing is
talking about funding a a large a large
body of workers who would be empowered
to go into people's houses uh visit them
at home and um provide what's called
informal and motivational counseling so
informal counseling motivational
counseling and quote other services that
the commissioner defines by
rules that seems to me an
extraordinarily vague definition for
responsibilities for somebody who does
not have any medical credentials to
speak of that would we we would be
offering a
certification in order to cover their
services under our Medicaid
Program I would assert that that is a a
rather substantial expansion of
government it puts us on the hook for
approximately $4.2 million in the next
budget cycle uh actually in the first
year of the next budget cycle I should
say and an indeterminant amount of
expens expenditure
thereafter Mr Speaker I urge my
colleagues to vote um no on the a to
pass motion so that a better motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
Weber thank you Mr
Speaker so House Bill 403 does a bunch
of things because it's one of those
omnibus Bills first it extends the
deadline for the legislative committee
on interdisciplinary Primary Care
Workforce issues which I think we've
already done once
already second with respect to lnas
licensed nurse
assistants currently under
rule they must work for two years
full-time in a nursing home or other
occupational setting before they can
even take the training and then the
certification to be a
medication uh to administer
medications
so this is of concern to our nursing
homes and other health care
entities and the committee believed that
lowering the amount of time you have to
work before you can take the training
and the certification exam to a year of
full-time employment was reasonable and
it will certainly help with our health
care crisis because it will increase the
number of people who can assist with
medication administration so that's
number
two then there's the community health
workers and there is no overlap with
what the other currently licensed
professions do
what the community health workers do is
they are a liaison between patients and
the Health Care System particularly for
people who find the Health Care System
particularly bewildering or
inaccessible so they help people get to
their
appointments they help people get their
medications they help people find free
cancer SC screenings the joy of this
position is that these people the
healthc care workers establish a rapport
with a patient who may otherwise have
real barriers to obtaining Health Care
in a timely and appropriate Manner and
get them to early care early help and
get them to be the healthiest person
they can possibly possibly be they also
help with things like food distributions
social
supports and other things that just make
for a healthier
population just managing to uh avoid the
no-show appointments when somebody
suddenly realizes they can't get to
their appointment is a real Boon for all
of us because it makes the Health Care
system work better for all of
us currently these positions are often
funded by grants and the grants are for
a year or for two years or for 3 years
and you just get a good robust system
going and the grant runs out and the
system falls apart and the wheels come
off and some of the workers decide that
they really need to go and do some other
kind of work because although they love
this job they need a job so what this
bill does is it allows certification
and Medicaid funding for these positions
which make life considerably better for
the people receiving the services
considerably better for the people with
the
certification and somewhat better for
all the rest of us so I urge you to vote
Green in favor of opop pass's amendment
and I ask for a division vote Mr
Speaker representative Granger res
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is on to pass and
Senate Bill 403 it's a roll call vote
chair recognized representative kofalt
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
Senate Bill 403 is a massive expansion
of our state's Medicaid Program for
services that are vaguely defined and
stand to increase the state spending by
over $ million per year going into the
Future Would I then press the red button
thank you chair recognize representative
Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if if I recognize that certification of
healthc care workers is
voluntary and is very good public policy
in that it will result in a healthier
Workforce and a healthier
population and if I know that if we are
successful in passing the policy the
financial aspects will of course be
reviewed by the finance committee would
I now press the green button to pass
this
bill motion before us is autop pass and
Senate Bill 403 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
represent
all members present had an opportunity
vote 188 voting aay yay
1878 voting nay commit report is adopted
for what reason is a member rise uh for
a question of the speaker okay Mr
Speaker a long time ago we dispensed
with uh what I lovingly call the the
Walk of Shame when people failed to vote
um on a roll call vote they had to come
down declare their vote and apologize
for not voting we did away with it to
save time we we felt that it would save
time by simply doing a thumbs up or a
thumbs down but it seems that we have
more and more people failing to vote and
it taking the time of the clerk it's
taking the time of the house and I was
wondering Mr Speaker if you'd like to go
back to our our previous practice of
having people come down to declare their
vote and apologize for not voting in a
timely manner so that we can speed these
proceedings
along house will Bey an order
Mr the uh chair recognizes a clerk for a
senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 103
relative to name changes for inmates
felons representative Lynn moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh colleagues you
may recall this bill was was passed uh
on a unanimous either unanimous or 19
to1 recommendation of the Judiciary
Committee it passed on the consent
calendar it essentially changes the
procedure by which a person can petition
for name change to deal with the
situation of people who petition for
name change if they have a criminal
record or are serving a sentence that
kind of thing um we sent it over to the
Senate on the consent calendar the
Senate made a very minor uh technical
change that actually improves the bill
the way the bill was worded as it left
us was to say that if somebody is
incarcerated before they the name change
competition can go forward the
Department of Corrections has to be
notified it didn't say and in addition
to that the department of safety has to
be not notified the Senate made that
change which is a beneficial change um
apparently Corrections and safety don't
always talk to each other I'm quite sure
why but they don't so I uh I we I
canvased our committee uh today
everybody is agreeable to uh uh that we
concurrence motion before secur on House
Bill one3 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have
majority of committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred Senate Bill 456 FN an
act relative to the state loan repayment
program for qualified nursing
professionals making an appropriation
therefore consider this and Report the
same with the recommendation the bill
ought to pass pres of Joe Shapiro for
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
following resolution resolv that is
inexpedient to legislate sentive Bill
King for the minority of the committee
King thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker and esteemed
colleagues the demand for nurses has
been a problem even before 20 20 and
that problem grew expens exponentially
after
2020 if an evaluation of the problem was
broken down we would find that there
were a number of conditions contributing
to today's shortage from Millennial
career selections and working
motivations to the hospital work
environment and paygrades to economic
conditions in New Hampshire there are a
number of reasons the number of people
selecting nursing as a career are
numerous
Senate Bill
456 is a bill that has has determined
one solution is to throw money at the
problem by offering funds toward student
loan forgiveness in committee we heard
people testify that offering such a
benefit will incentivize nurses to stay
in New Hampshire I will admit this type
of benefit has been successful placing
lawyers and teachers in economically
struggling areas is over a period of
time in return for forgiving their
school loans this forgiveness comes with
the condition that these professionals
remain in these depressed areas for 10
years and even then it is only a portion
of the student
loan this bill does not put any of these
conditions on the bill which will allow
a nursing professional to move on to
greener pastures with no
recourse I have worked in industry for
nearly third 40 years part of my
responsibilities included hiring people
mentoring successors and eventually
growing them into positions of their
dreams I rarely if ever found people
interested in money to motivate them and
if it did it was only
temporary we need to focus on the work
environment and the individuals in their
work environment this is the key to
solving our nursing shortage this bill
allots $300,000
for this benefit giving this money away
to incentivize professional n nurses
with no condition is not wise and a
gamble we do not want to gamble with the
taxpayers money I ask you to join me in
selecting the red button so we can
consider another motion to be made and
Mr Speaker I request a division vote
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognized
thank you Mr
Speaker I come before you today in
support of s SP 456 a bill that will
make a modest but much needed expansion
of the student student loan repayment
program otherwise known as slurp within
the Department of Health and Human
Services office of rural Health this
bill makes an appropriation of $300,000
specifically directed to nursing
professionals working in Primary Care
settings in Rural and medically
underserved areas of New
Hampshire while we know that there's a
Workforce shortage generally in the
health care field the shortage of
nursing is particularly acute forcing
many provider organizations to hire High
numbers of traveling nurses and not
infrequently forcing limits on bed
capacities in hospitals and long-term
care
in my community Maplewood nursing home
chesher County's facility completed
extensive Renovations in
2021 it is a beautiful facility but
unfortunately onethird of the beds are
closed due to staff
shortages currently the student loan rep
repayment program has 100 active
participants providing assistance with
student loans to Medical providers of
all
kinds 25 of of whom are RNs and nurse
practitioners without expanding the
eligibility criteria this new
appropriation of just
$300,000 will provide loan repayment for
an additional 6 to 10 full-time nurses
or as many as
17 part-time
nurses we understand that the healthcare
Workforce shortage is complex it's a
complex puzzle with multiple causes high
student loan burden which average
between 40 and
$55,000 upon completion of an RN degree
are just one stressor for those in the
field nevertheless student loan
repayment is an effective proven method
of recruiting and retaining workers it
will help to retain nurses who may be
tempted by more Rob robust repayment
programs in neighboring states most
importantly The increased assistance
that this Pro appropriation will provide
will will be extremely meaningful to
both individual nurses and the
organizations that employ them I urge
you to support the bipartisan
recommendation of aut to pass on S SP
456 which will make a small but
meaningful investment in our healthc
care Workforce by pushing the green
you the motion before us is a to pass on
a
division sen of King has requested a
motion before is a to pass on Senate V
456 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Bill king for
a parliamentary
inquiry the house will be in
order thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know there are no guarantees to keep
incentivized nurses in New Hampshire and
if I know pro professional nurses have
many economical lucrative options in
other states and if I know we have a
responsibility to spend our constituents
tax money wisely would I now press
the red button so another motion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Shapiro for
parliamentary GR
Mr Speaker if I know that the student
loan repayment program has been a
particularly good thing for hiring and
retaining workers that are federally
qualified Health Centers and if I know
that a little more of a good thing is a
very good thing would I then Mr Speaker
push the green button and give our
hardworking nurses the support that they
deserve motion before us is a to pass on
Senate Bill 456 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press agre
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members president opportunity to
vote 187 voting a 177 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's going to
finance
majority committee on Health and Human
Service and elderly Affairs to which is
referred Senate Bill 496 FN and act
directing the Department of Health and
Human Services to establish a climate
and health Protection Program having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution ution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Bill King the majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority of Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass from Mr Joe Shapiro from the
minority of the committee chair
Shapiro thank you Mr
Speaker I stand before you this
afternoon to urge you to defeat the I
itl recommendation on SP
496 A bill that would require Department
of Health and Human Services to
reestablish a climate and health
Protection Program such a program which
actually existed within DHHS between
2013 and 2022 would be tasked with
collecting and analyzing data on current
emerging impacts on human health related
to the changing
environment devel veloping strategies to
respond to emerging Health threats and
providing education and resources to New
Hampshire
residents it is clear that climate
warming has and will continue to amplify
and accelerate changes in our
environment causing significant health
challenges such as increases in
tickborne illnesses heat related
injuries stress and injury related to
extreme weather and wild wild
wildfire and smoke related dangers one
new concern is the northern progression
progression of mosquito born malaria
which is now affecting areas south of
us while the structure for such a
program will be at the discretion of the
commissioner it should be noted that
previously a grant funded position did
exist within the department since no
appropriation is included in this bill
any additional funding to support
additional staff positions or or other
expenses would have to be raised through
new grants at no expense to the
taxpayers no new expense to the
taxpayers how do we know we need this we
certain certainly can't predict the
future that's the whole point
establishing a climate and health
Protection Program now will allow us to
be ready later when we need to make
adjustments to climate impacts that we
can't yet see or even
imagine this is a common sense no
expense effort to lay the groundwork for
future threats to protect the public
health of New Hampshire residents once
again I urge you to push the red button
to defeat the itl motion so that a
better motion may be made be like a Boy
Scout be
prepared and Mr Speaker I request a
division
King do a member yelder a question
do thank you representative would this
Protection Program address the acute and
chronic effects from cyanotoxin exposure
which has been on the increase with the
Lakes thank you for the question this is
this is precisely the type of impacts
that this program would study analyze
and make recommendations about both for
Community Health um in this case and for
individual health threats that um that
pose chair recognized representative
Bill
King thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker in
recent years we have seen an increase in
tornadoes stronger hurricanes warmer
weather and health issues related to
these climate
changes Senate Bill 486 is about adding
more work to the already strained
resources at the Department of Health
and Human res uh Human
Services the the work needed included
compiling information we already
obtained during a previous DHHS
assignment and distributing educational
information warning the population of
health concerns impacting impacted by
climate
change to reduce the strain on the
already bustling DHHS Workforce there
would be a plan to hire a person to
oversee this effort at a cost of
approximately
$165,000 per year over the next three
years whether you believe in climate
change or not there is supporting
evidence that wildfires has caused
respiratory issues in people of all ages
it is true that there are more cases of
tickborne
illnesses also true is that there are
more cas cases of heat related health
issues the question comes down to do we
need to spend
money uh to conduct a duplicate study
and to further educate our constituents
of these health concerns I believe
everyone listening to this speech knows
enough to stay inside if there are wild
wildfires in Canada affecting our air
quality we know what a tick bite looks
like and what to do if we see one we
know to drink more water and keep
ourselves cool during successive hot
days and malaria if that day comes
although new new to New England it is
not a new illness we have not dealt with
in other areas if we burden DHHS with
this work it will further strain their
workload that is already involved in
dealing with our drug and alcohol
effects uh drug and alcohol effects on
our New Hampshire communities and
businesses managing Medicare our sorry
Medicaid dealing with our state's Mental
Health crisis and other Health and Human
Service related concerns that impact our
daily lives today in order to lighten
this burden the alternative would cost
money to our already bulging
budget I ask you to join me by selecting
the green button to vote itl on Senate
thank you Mr sen Granger has asked for
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us majority committee
report of index meeting to legisl sen
Bill 496 this is a roll call vote CH
recognized represent choll for a
Mr
Speaker if I know that as a 20-year-old
I had to travel all the way to the
Pacific coast of southern Mexico to
contract malaria and Mr Speaker if I
know that I want to be preped be
prepared to avoid those nasty mosquitoes
when they arrive in New Hampshire would
I then push the red button to defeat the
chair recognized representative Bill
King for parliamentary
inquiry Mr
Speaker if I know to stay inside when
the air quality is poor and if I know
what a tick bite looks like and what to
do if I see one and if I know that DHHS
is already overloaded with other health
related concerns with no immediate
answers would I now hit the green button
to it to um itl this bill and move on to
other business thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us majority committee
report of nxp to legisla and Senate Bill
496 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 186 voting a 182 voting a committee
house will be in
order majority of the committee on
Health and Human Services in LLY Affairs
to which was referred Senate Bill 567 FN
an act directing the commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
to comply compile a report on the
availability of M Prestone and missell
prestol having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate sen Le Missour for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee we
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Lucy Weber for the
minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Simpson Mr Speaker I Rise an opposition
to the itl motion on SB
567 and I urge my colleagues who support
medication abortion and the importance
of access to medication abortion to vote
no on this motion SB 567 directs the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services to issue a report identifying
actions to protect and expand access to
the two pills used for medication
abortion medication abortion is only
available up until the 11th week of
pregnancy I want to clear up any
confusion as to why these two pills are
the focus of this bill
on March 26th the US Supreme Court heard
oral arguments on a case that could
drastically restrict MFA Prestone the
first pill of medication
abortion across the country mffa
Prestone is safe effective and has been
used by more than 5 million people in
the United States for abortion and for
miscarriage care since the FDA approved
it more than 20 years ago the me the
member will suspend the me member has a
right to be heard if you have to have a
conversation take it out into the Ane
room the member may continue thank you
Mr Speaker Mya prisone has helped ensure
that patients are able to make their own
private medical decisions and has
expanded access to reproductive health
care but this is under dire threat in
our country as we continue to see state
after State Banning abortion earlier and
earlier just yesterday Florida six- we
abortion ban took effect the six-week
ban impacts individuals who live in
Florida but also pregnant women in
nearby states with abortion banss who
until yesterday had been able to travel
to Florida to get the care that they
needed access to abortion including
medication abortion is Central to
people's ability to participate equally
in economic and social life in New
Hampshire and across the country access
to medication abortion specifically is a
a key component to protecting indivi in
individuals freedom to control their own
body life and
future a decision from the US Supreme
Court about the future of mistone is
expected in the next few weeks s SP 567
would support efforts to protect and
expand access to medication abortion to
identify ways to increase outrate
Outreach about accessing medication
abortion and to identify the barriers
that exist
to protecting or expanding access to
medication abortion s SP 567 was passed
in the other chamber on a Voice vote
this bill came to us with strong
bipartisan support knowing full well
what's at stake with the US Supreme
Court case regarding abortion please
join me in voting against the itl motion
so that another motion may be made and
Mr Speaker I'd like a division vote
please thank you chair recognizes the
thank you Mr
Speaker in committee there was concern
over why these two drugs were singled
out for a report why not compile a
report on the availability of other
drugs then the US Food and Drug
Administration an agency within
DHHS already regulates the approval
distribution and use of pharmaceuticals
like muf pistone and
misoprostol compiling a detailed report
on the availability of these specific
Pharmaceuticals would be redundant given
existing oversight
mechanisms also various stakeholders
such as pharmaceutical companies Health
Care Providers and public health
organizations already track the use and
availability of these drugs a separate
report would not add substantial new
information to what they are gathering
on a daily basis we have no data to show
the availability of these drugs is even
a problem and directing DHHS to do this
would add an unneeded task to their
already full
workload it would require Personnel
Resources that should be allocated to
other pressing public health
issues this bill would also require
additional Financial Resources as the
department anticipates that it will need
to hire a new staff position to oversee
the work required by it DHHS is unable
to determine whether there will be costs
in fiscal years 2026 and 27 as the bill
is not specific with respect to their
responsibilities involved with quote
protecting and expanding access end
quote to these drug drugs this bill was
deemed unnecessary by our committee
committee
majority please press the green button
to concur with their itl recommendation
thank
you the division has been called for
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote
the motion before us majority committer
report of inexpedient to legislate on
Senate Bill 567 this is a division vote
Cher and I represent Simpson for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that
medication abortion is under attack in a
current US Supreme Court case and if I
also know that medication abortion which
includes both mistone and Miss mprosta
is only available to patients up until
the 11th week of a
pregnancy and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that Granite Staters need access to
mistone and Misa prol which are both
vital medications for abortion and
miscarriage care and that we need to
know if there are disparities in Access
across the state would I now vote red
against the itl so another motion may be
brought
forward chair recognized representative
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know there is concern over
why these two drugs are being singled
out for a report and there is no data to
show the availability of these drugs is
even a problem and if I know that
directing DHHS to do this would add an
unneeded task to their already full
workload and require personnel and
financial resources that should be
allocated to other other pressing public
health issues and lastly if I know SP
567 was deemed unnecessary by the
bipartisan committee majority would I
please press the green button thank
you the motion before us on this
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislative sen B 567 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote 181 voting a 183 voting a the
motion
fails representative Weber moves ought
to
pass a division has been
seats representative H has requested a
roll call that is sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill
567 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 184 voting a 182 voting a committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
finance
committee on Judiciary to wish is
referred Senate Bill
435 act relative to New Hampshire unit
trust statute having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation to Bill ought
to pass with Amendment Representative
Bob blind for the committee the
amendment is
1454 printed in house record 17 Pages 46
through 51 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I I oppose nay the eyes have
it amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
adopted majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
63 it is way too noisy in
here an act relative to the adoption of
Public Health ordinances by
municipalities having considered the
same report the same with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Senor Tim kill for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Lori stavit
for the minority of the committee chair
hland thank you Mr Speaker uh Senate
Bill 63 amends RSA
1471 which provides the authority to the
municipal Public Health officer to make
regulations to prevent and remove
nuisances which are better known under
the category of toilets drains
expectoration rubbish and waste and
other uh related public health issues
and so the public health officer works
very similar to the uh municipal code
enforcement officer and in both cases
the state provides the guidelines and
the
regulations and then the uh local uh
Public Health officer in that that
regulation goes to the local governing
body where an ordinance is generated
that allows the authority of them to
enforce the state
regulations and so the this legislation
really seeks to narrow the scope of the
public health
officer and uh
intentionally that scope in nuisances
was broad because the state really
wasn't sure what nuisances would come
along and they wanted some flexibility
as they began to adopt regulations and
laws and ensure that the local public
health officer could enforce them and so
as we went through the public hearing it
there really was no clear um evidence
shown that the public health officers
was in fact coopting the power of the
state and generating legislation they
really were in fact enforcement
another concern that was raised is that
perhaps the public health officer would
work outside of nuisances and would in
fact try to address more uh significant
public health issues and in fact the
role of the P public health officer in
those conditions is clearly defined in
State legisl uh legislation and so for
example when you deal with uh
communicable or infectious diseases that
really resides under RSA
141 and again there the state has
control of the uh guidelines and
regulations and the role of the public
health officer is to report if outbreaks
are occurring in their communities and
then to enforce the guidelines and
regulations that the state uh is
enacting and that holds true through all
other public health uh issues including
up to Public Health Emergency
and so what the minority of the the
committee found is there really was
adequate safeguards in place for the
public health officer and there really
was no evidence that it needed to be
changed and so this is why the minority
of the committee recommended inexpedient
to legislate and we' hope you follow our
recommendation thank
you J recogniz representative Harve
bolia
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
in support of a motion of OTP on this
bill this bill clarifies what sorts of
ordinances can be enacted by towns under
this rarely used
law uh it doesn't prevent a health
officer from doing their job in any way
as you may have heard um in in fact the
enforcement mechanism of this law is
untouched it's later it's it's in 146
but it's we're not addressing that so um
this is just a very rarely used section
of the laws they said neither does it
prevent them from coordinating with DHHS
to address emergencies as some may have
claimed the president of the health
Officers Association and DHHS are
friendly to this language and the
language is consistent with everything
that DHHS already has in their guidance
documents three reasons why we need this
bill though first in testimony we heard
how towns were passing ordinances which
required additional fees additional
licensing even and other onerous
requirements which serve to gatekeep
certain businesses out of town similar
to a zoning ordinance for instance
several towns have enacted Health
ordinances requiring that only
Physicians can open tattoo parlors or
pierce ears
even and Mr Speaker we all know about
how mask mandates were enacted using
this law but did you know that Handover
also used this law to mandate that
people needed to keep lists of
visitors appearing in their homes and if
they had more than 10 guests they needed
a permit to have those
guests second there's no public hearing
requirement under this section of Law
and no over oversight by DHHS when an
ordinance is
passed finally Health officers are
usually only part-time employees and in
some cases unpaid
volunteers who who need just three hours
of training which I hear is that is also
not enforced by
DHHS three hours of training is not
sufficient training to pass Health
mandates which affect the population of
an entire town without some
oversight that is why we employ epidemi
epidemiologists we've already voted and
passed a different version of this bill
under a different title last year please
vote for this Common Sense change you
press the green button and Mr Speaker i'
request a division
vote representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autop pass on Senate
Bill 63 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative mag leor
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire accepts the
broad authority of Health officers to
navig to investigate public health and
sanitary concerns and if I know this
broad Authority is required because
Public Health officials must be able to
respond in a timely and effective manner
to infinite threats to Public Health and
Mr Speaker if I know that legislators
have consistently created amended and
added to statutes to recognize several
of these Public Health threats including
sewage contaminants and soils
contaminantes and groundwater biological
hazards in swimming pools and bathing
places threats for marine species asbest
and every sort of communicable disease
including measles then Mr Speaker would
would I vote no on this motion by
pressing the red button so that another
motion can be made to preserve the
authority of local Health officers to
safeguard our communities thank you Mr
Speaker your recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill simply affirms
the legislative intent of the statute
granting Town Health offices the
authority to make Town Health ordinances
and if I know that this Authority given
to town Health officers by the state
legislature pertains specifically to
nuisances affecting Public Health which
is well defined in law and finally if I
know that this bill does not affect the
ability of state government state
agencies or local emergency responders
to make approp to take appropriate
actions as Allowed by law in response to
any emergency within the state would I
now vote Yes to support the committee
recommendation of ought to pass and push
the green button thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us majority committee
report of a to pass and Senate Bill 63
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 181 in the majority voting yay 182
failed representative representative
stavis moves inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the for what
reason does the member rise move to
63 motion before us is
63 are you ready for the question all
I those oppose
nay eyes have it Senate Bill 63 is laid
the majority the committee on Municipal
and County government which is referred
Senate Bill 538 local an act relative to
zoning procedures concerning residential
housing having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
lenot for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative David priest for the
representative Alexander is recognized
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I'm here today to express my unwavering
support for at Senate Bill 538 a
completely enabling bill that allows
individual towns to utilize additional
tools to increase the supply of housing
this bill does three things it allows
for office based conversion zones
converting old structures into
residential housing it allows for the
local legislative body to accept
Amendments of to zoning procedures and
allows for more flexibility in parking
Arrangements all of these items are
purely tools the towns can choose to
participate in should they want to I'm
not shocked that Municipal and County
government committee would recommend
killing another bill related to
housing Mr Speaker did you create a
special committee for that very reason
only time will
tell a completely optional bill for
towns will would meet a cruel death in
Municipal and County government
committee please vote no on the itl pass
you representative priest has recognized
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
Rise to oppose the motion of itl of SB
538 according to the most recent housing
needs assessment New Hampshire is
grappling with a staggering demand for
housing with approximately
24,000 units urgently needed in the
grand
estate the New Hampshire housing crisis
has become an economic challenge the
housing shortage is hampering our
state's ability to attract and retain
young and diverse work work force a
crucial factor in maintaining a robust
and resilient
economy as older Grand estaters leave
the
workforce the housing shortage will
leave businesses struggling to hire
skilled talented and a diverse
Workforce as new potential workers may
need help in finding affordable housing
in New Hampshire
we have a problem and we have to do
something about this the bipartisan Bill
SB
538 would Pro would provide towns and
cities with tools to address the New
Hampshire housing crisis and respect
their local
control the bill will provide three
tools that are all discretionary to the
local legislative bodies and their
planning
commissions the F the First Tool in
section three of the bill would enable a
local tax credit options for owners of
property converted from Office
Industrial and Commercial space to
residential
units the term of the local tax option
is at the local government's legislative
body descrip
and it's usually 3 to 5 years this is to
help offset the construction cost the
project must conform to local Planning
and
Zoning the second tools section five of
the bill would enable local legislative
bodies to enact zoning amendments about
housing more than once a year the
amendments approval will will require at
least one full public hearing
consultation with the local planning
board and compliance with the
municipality's master plan SB 538
wouldn't a municipalities to improve and
add housing units more
efficiently the third tool section six
of the bill will provide the planning
board and the local governing board to
consider an alternative parking solution
the applicant proposes to meet the
proposed parking demand created by the
proposed residential
use the alternative parking solution
will substitute for meeting the onsite
parking requirements prescribed by the
zoning
ordinance the municipal and County
government heard many individuals from
Real Estate economic development
business interest and from towns and
cities that New Hampshire has a severe
housing crisis the lack of Housing and
its affordability are affecting our
businesses our economy and our labor
market something has to be done the
bipartisan Bill and SB
538 enforces local control and provides
the local governing boards to use three
new tools to address the housing
shortage in their
communities I urge all of you to oppose
the motion of
itlb
538 so that another motion can be made
and Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
thank
you representative Powers recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the motion inexpedient to
legislate on Senate Bell
538 Mr Speaker I fully acknowledge the
fact that here in the granite state
there's a housing crisis as a result
year after year we see a number of bills
that seek to address this issue some of
which are effective and others like this
bill which does very little to actually
address the problem and instead creates
new problems now let me
explain first this bill incentivizes the
conversion of office industrial or
commercial spaces to residential use by
giving Property Owners tax relief for up
to5
years understand that this tax relief is
not free since the tax burden will be
subsidized by the rest of the taxpayers
in the town or city again for up to 15
years moreover an unintended consequence
of this bill is that businesses will be
disrupted when their leases are not
renewed and the business space they
occupy is is converted to residential
use forcing these business businesses to
have to
relocate and find new business space if
they can as a result this bill will hurt
taxpayers as well as business owners
second this bill not only requires the
planning board to consider proposals for
alternative Parking Solutions to on-site
parking requirements it goes a step
further penalizing the planning board if
it does not approve the alternative
parking proposal for any reason and it
also requires the planning board instead
of the applicant to both request and pay
for a thirdparty
review notably these new requirements
are in direct contrast with how third
party reviews are currently conducted
under law as a result this bill mandates
new costs to municipalities and creates
conflicts in statute with chapter
676 f finally and most detrimental this
bill enables a town to give the select
board the permanent authority to propose
and to approve zoning amendments at any
time after a single public Hearing in
other words this bill essentially
removes the planning board's authority
to both study and to propose zoning
amendments ensuring consistency with the
Town Master Plan and it also Str strips
the town residents of the ability to to
approve zoning amendments by official
ballot on Town election day eradicating
the current system of checks and
balances as a result this bill
fundamentally changes the function and
the structure of Municipal local
government and creates more unresolved
statutory conflicts with chapter 675 and
possibly other RSA
to conclude Senate Bill 538
disadvantages taxpayers and business
tenants it erodes the structure and
function of municipal government and
creates conflicts in stature and statute
therefore I urge my fellow colleagues to
support the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate by voting yes
on Senate Bill 538 and I ask for a
the questions on the majority committee
report event expedience to legislate on
Senate Bill 538 representative priest
requested a division this will be a
seats representative H is ask for a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
May
let's get that aisle clear and find our
seats
questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
on Senate Bill
538 let's quiet down so that
representative stavis can be heard when
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know and we've all acknowledged
that there simply isn't enough housing
in New Hampshire to sustain the
workforce we need and if I know that
this lack of housing threatens our
businesses our economy and our society
and if I know that a few simple
adjustments to our zoning and planning
procedures would encourage a modest
increase in this desperately needed
Supply if I further know that s SP 538
Builds on existing and very successful
law to turn unused commercial space into
new residences while providing
Innovative tools for planning boards
when considering new housing in their
communities and if I also know that it
has been amended to include language
that this house has supported in a
previous bill would I now press the
green button to support the autop pass
emotion and show that we are serious
about our responsibility to meet this
my apologies would I now press the red
button to overturn the itl motion so
made representative poers recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill does very
little to actually help the housing
crisis and if I know that in fact this
bill is extremely ill advised as it
displaces business tenants making them
homeless when business space is
converted to residential use it burdens
taxpayers requiring them to subsidize
long-term tax relief incentives for up
to 15 years it erodes the structure and
function of municipal government by
transferring zoning Amendment
authorities from the planning board and
the voters to a small group of Selectmen
and it also also creates new conflicts
in statutes would I now vote Yes to
support the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate and push the
green button thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate and Senate Bill 538 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 188 in the affirmative 173 and the
the Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred Senate
Bill 476 FN an act making a capital
appropriation to the Department of
Corrections toward the replacement of
the New Hampshire state prison for men
having consider the same report the same
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Bill Boyd
for the
committee representative kazinski is
recognized to speak against the
thank you thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to SB 476 you're going to
want to lift that microphone up a little
bit pardon pull the microphone up a
little closer to you okay um this bill
seeks to bond $40
million for design and Engineering of
the new Men's
prison last year the house gave 50
million in general fund revenues for
this
project the body on the other side saw
fit to remove 40 million of that to
spend El
elsewhere now one short year later that
same body seeks $40 million in bonding
only with an interest cost of 21 million
estimated a 42%
increase the 10 million they already
have in Corrections plus 40 million plus
21 million in interest equals $71
million total cost and that's just for
the design and Engineering of the jail
the most recent estimate for this prison
is 600 million so that's a total of 671
million the question is not if we're
going to be should build a new prison or
not the money was already appropriated
for that last year it's just that the
$21 million
is too much to add this Project's been
talked about for several years and it
will take several years to complete so
what's the rush with this bill it's too
late in the banum to add this
expenditure it should be properly P
placed in the next budget cycle we
should be good stewards of our
constituents tax
dollars I urge you to press the red
button so another and better motion can
be made and Mr Speaker I request a roll
Speaker representative mcon is
report thank you Mr Speaker uh before I
begin my remarks I must uh tell you of a
shortcoming of my
own after we had left the legisl after
we had exacted Senate bill for 76 the uh
the gentleman before you a valued
Committee Member had asked myself to put
in a Minority
Report I received that at my home and
the only excuse I have is busy and it
didn't make it into the so I apologize
legislature now to the issue at hand the
committee report is thorough addressing
the many failings of the current men's
state prison located just down the road
the most striking fact is that the
committee
report contained a $40 million
expenditure in last year's Senate Bill
two but was removed so here we are with
an
expenditure a large expenditure on a uh
offe
request before we held our hearing we
toured the prison to see the current
conditions and it's no better than when
I toured it six years prior and has
greater
issues for our own benefit we asked the
treasurer to come to the committee and
speak on what effect this would have on
our recently upgraded Bond rating could
she came forward and said while she
would not like to see this sort of
expenditure brought forward off seon as
it is
now that the the state has the
wish so that that took that burden away
knowing that every project that I've
ever been involved in in my 10e with
whether it was the widening of 93 that
started out at $100 million and ended at
$250
million the women's
prison that took us an extra I think it
was four years to construct because we
didn't have enough of an appropriation
in there and when we brought it forward
to get the final appropriation again it
cost us millions of dollars
more further knowing that there are only
um companies out there that even uh
address how to build a
Penitentiary delays make this worse so I
ask is I ask you to vote with the
majority opinion of Public Works and
press the green button when the
you okay
okay questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on Senate Bill 476
question whoa whoa whoa who's asking
who's asking for a roll call
Representative H has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
let's make it a roll call vote members
EX
the questions on the majority committee
report about brought to pass on Senate
Bill
476 this is a roll call
vote the house will come to
order representative Melvin's recognized
inquiry Mr Speaker Mr Speaker first time
at
well if I know that the $50 million in
House Bill 2 was for the new prison
design was reduced by $40 million and
the money was spent by the body on the
other side for something else which I
don't know and if I know that this bill
would add $40 million back into the form
of bonding but would add $21 million in
interest which is 42% % increase would I
now press the red button so another
motion can be made and thank you Mr
Speaker representative mcon is
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if you know that I do not
typically favor a new capital
expenditure in an off year and if you
further know that the treasurer has
assured the committee that this
expenditure will not affect our bond
rating and finally if I know a one-year
delay will only slow the planning
process and cost us millions of dollars
in construction cost would I now uphold
the majority committee position and pass
this along to finance so they can make a
you the questions on the majority
committee report about pass and Senate
Bill 476 as a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 2117 in the affirmative 144 and the
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side on S SP 219 I would like
to move to
reconsider
319 and speak to my
motion what SP 319 SP 219 that's what I
said
yes oh the very last bill that we did is
can't you
recognized representative Reed moves
reconsideration of Senate Bill 219 and
is recognized speak for a motion and the
house will be in order thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker no knowing that I
fully support transparency and
originally voted for this bill I thought
that it applied equally to all kinds of
schools and it does not and while I
would support the bill with an amendment
reconsider who requested the roll
call yeah representative whole requested
the roll call it's sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion is to reconsider Senate Bill
219 representative luno is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that now would be a good time to
reconsider Senate Bill 219 that wouldn't
I press the green button to do just that
right now thank
you representative lad's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know that school
districts have both the data and the
skills to produce this information and
if I know that taxpayers both expect and
deserve transparency in how their money
is being spent
would I then press the red button thank
you the motion is whether to reconsider
setup Bill 219 roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house liend to
the state of the
vote 185 in the affirmative 181 in the
passes we are back to the motion of
vote representative veral requests the
roll call it is sufficiently seconded
it'll be a roll call vote roll V members
motion is asked to pass on Senate Bill
219 representative B Bon is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is
unnecessary because this information is
readily available on the Department of
Education website and additional
financial information required by law is
publicly available by school
districts and if I know that local
financial reporting decisions should be
made by local school boards then would I
now press the red button to allow
another another motion to be made thank
you representative Noble's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that school districts
have both the data and the skills to
produce this
information and if I know that taxpayers
both
expect and deserve transparency for how
their money is being spent then would I
you the questions on the motion about to
pass on Senate Bill 219 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppos press the red voting
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attender the state
of the vote
182 in the affirmative 184 in the
fails
representative C mov I for what reason
does the member rise Mr Speaker I move
to table Senate Bill
219 representive Sweeney moves to table
Senate Bill 219 are you ready for the
question y okay it'll be a division vote
the motion is to table of Senate 219
representative sweene is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the earlier
vote today was a bipartisan vote to pass
this bill and further Mr Speaker if I
know one of the reasons cited to
reconsider the legislation was to open
it up to possible amendments would I now
press the green button to place this
bill on the table so a bipartisan group
of legislators could work on amending
the underlying Bill uh to stick to why
we reconsidered in the first place thank
you thank you representative luno is
recognized for parliamentary
inqu thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that there's a better motion than
table to be uh to be made wouldn't I
press the red button to defeat the
tabling motion so that we could make
that motion next thank
you question is whether lay Senate Bill
219 on the table if you're in favor
press the green button oppose press the
red voting stations are open for 30
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attendance state of the vote which
includes my
vote 184 in the affirmative 183 in the
committee on resource requisition and
development which to where referred
Senate Bill 492 act relative to
Wastewater engineering having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
Rosemary rung for the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no the
eyes have it and the committee report is
Means majority committee on science
technology and energy to which is
referred Senate Bill 386 act relative to
establishing a commit to study power
generation transmission distribution and
storage and considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment Senator Michael votes for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
as inexpedient to
legislate presentor Tony Kaplan for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does a member rise motion to
table s SP
386 the motion is in order the motion
question division has been requested
the motion before us is the table house
bill Senate Senate Bill
386 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Johnson all members president have
opportunity to vote H will tend to stay
to the
vote 348 voting a 11 voting a Senate
table majority of the committee on
science technology and any to which was
referred Senate Bill 449 act relative to
the permit Insurance timeline for State
air permits considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Mel votes for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate reprentative
Chris mums for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 1565 printed
in house record 17 Pages 51- 52 are you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is our
to pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
adopted majority committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred Senate Bill 540 an act
requiring the department of energy to
investigate behind the meter and utility
scale energy storage consider the same
report the same the the recommendation
of Bill be referred for interim study JD
Bernardi for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass representative Thomas Corman for
the minority of the committee chair
Corman thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
you might recall that when we
deliberated HB
1623 a few weeks ago I delivered a pi
and in that Pi I pointed out that my
good friend from eping who sponsored the
bill referred to the bill as the New
Hampshire energy Independence act and at
the time I disparaged the idea that we
could become energy independent and part
of my argument was that we rely on oil
we rely on natural gas and as far as I
know we don't produce either of those in
New
Hampshire maybe we'll someday have a Jed
clampet who shoots at some food and up
through the ground comes a bubble and
crude but I'm not betting on
that
so it it is not feasible for us to
become
entirely energy
independent it is however a nice
thought and what we can do is become
less energy energy
dependent how can we do
that we can produce energy in New
Hampshire in fact we do and one of the
ways that we do is with solar and
another way that we do is with wind
they're renewable and they produce no
carbon those are good
things but they are not reliable there
are long periods of time where the sun
doesn't shine and there are also periods
of time when the wind doesn't blow
so what can we do about that we can
store that energy so that we can use it
during those times that we don't have
sunshine or wind and also that enables
us to smooth out the load on the grid
which actually will reduce rates because
the grid has to be built for the
maximum energy that goes on it if we can
actually smooth it out that reduces
rates
hence batteries batteries are a way that
we can become less energy dependent and
have reliable renewable clean
energy so now the question is how
feasible is battery storage and the
answer is it's really becoming
increasingly feasible we're seeing
utility scale storage happening in
several
States and it's even planned now for
Marx station in bu
when they convert to solar and get off
coal there's also a lot of what's called
behindth meter battery storage for
example I have batteries at my house I
not only talk the talk I walk the walk I
have solar panels I have batteries and
I'm hardly ever using the
grid so batteries really are important
to our Energy Future but we don't know
that much about them as a state we don't
really know what to do and the
technology of batteries is changing more
rapidly than really any other energy
technology you know we're all used to
lithium ion batteries and I know some
people think of them as heavy because
EVS are
heavy but actually as batteries go
lithium ion are pretty
lightweight but if you think about it
when we're talking about utility scale
storage or even batteries in your home
who cares how much they weigh and there
are new battery technologies that have
heavier batteries but with really good
qualities there's something called an
iron air battery where actually the
battery rusts and dust to discharge and
charge and those are coming those are
actually commercially feasible now there
are also things called solid state
batteries and I won't go into what that
is about because I'd like you to stay
awake until the end of my
speech so what does this bill do it just
simply has the department of energy
study storage technology how to
encourage investing in it and identify
regulatory hurdles and Market barri
barriers batteries are going to be an
important part of our Energy
Future our state needs to be ready and
this bill will help us be ready so I
hope that we can overturn the interim
study this interim study yes interim
study and go to another motion
Mr Speaker I request a division
Bernardi thank you Mr
Speaker so as you heard this is a
battery study
bill there's an existing
do uh or doe statute or chapter that
already requires the department of
energy to study battery techn
technology what this bill does is divide
that up into two different
taskings the first tasking is to look at
the financial regulatory legislative and
Market hurdles or barriers to advance
utility scale storage including utility
investment the problem with that and the
problem with the initial statute is the
Department of energy has no legitimate
function to do that
task this is the province or that is the
province and a utility scale storage is
the province of the iso New England
group they regulate utility production
and storage at that scale doe does not
we divested all our power plants all our
power production from the utilities and
they are now under ISO New
England the second half for the bill
addresses the financial regulatory
legislative and Market hurdles or
barriers for behind the meter customer
energy storage so as an example and one
was given by my colleague another might
be you have a Charged EV or you have a
EV charging station that's fully topped
off how do you turn that to feed the
grid as opposed to drawing from the grid
that is a potential legitimate area for
study and and greater
understanding the bill however has a
financial note of
$250,000 over two years if we take off
the utility scale storage that should
cut that in
half uh and since it already was a doe
mandate in previous legislation there
may not be any need for uh additional
funding
so the point now is that there is some
Merit to this bill some has no merit
hence I encourage you to vote for
interim study so we can figure out what
is useful and what isn't thank you very
much Mr
Speaker sen Corman has asked for a
division members take your seats this
vote
the motion before us is inm study on
Senate Bill 540 this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
empy thank you again Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that we need to become
less energy dependent and that batteries
are a really good part of that
solution and if I know that Battery
Technology is rapidly
evolving but that we need to stay ahead
of it and that this bill would help us
stay ahead of the technological changes
then Mr Speaker would I press the red
button so that a better motion can be
made chair recognize of V for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill doesn't ask the
right
questions and if I further know that the
department of energy is not going to be
able to make any progress on
significantly studying battery storage
based on this
bill what I press the green button to
sends this bill to interum study so we
can figure out what are the right
questions to ask thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is interim
study on Senate Bill 540 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you appros
you'll press the red button voting
well members present have the
opportunity to vote how will attend to
vote 188 voting a 171 voting a committee
majority of committee on science
technology and NG to which was referred
Senate Bill 603 FN an act relative to
telephone number and area code conver
conversation having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation Bill to pass
with Amendment sen Michael votes for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Thomas
Corman for the minority of the committee
having ruled that the majority committee
Amendment 1555 is non
Germain bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative V
offers Ms Amendment
1600h printed in house record 17 Pages
57 through 58 are you ready for the
question
speak and he representative o going to
it thank you Mr Speaker so on the very
last page of your calendar Pages 57 over
to
58 is the committee amendment that we
passed in committee
without a provision that was ruled by
the speaker to be non
gerain every other as part of that
amendment is identical to the amendment
we passed in
committee I urge you to adopt this
amendment and to adopt the bill itself
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion is on Amendment 1600h
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it the amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor all
right okay we got a debate chair
Speaker Mr Speaker if we do not pass
this bill New Hampshire will run out of
numbers in the 603 area code in the next
few years
and Mr Speaker if we do pass this bill
New Hampshire will run out of numbers in
the area code 603 in the next few
years either way we're running out of
numbers in the 603 area code it is
inevitable it is just not a matter of if
but
when so this bill spends somewhere
between 100,000 and 300,000 000 to try
to delay the
inevitable Mr Speaker I don't think this
sounds fiscally
responsible we'd be spending up to
$300,000 just to Kick the Can down the
road if we're going to spend $300,000 to
kick a
can we need to get someone really good
at
kicking perhaps Mr Speaker we could get
$300,000 but I don't think this is a
great use of our money now I understand
that some people tie their New Hampshire
identity into their 603 number I get
that you know I see 603 merch all over
the
place suppose we get a new area code
it's going to be what's called an
overlay the state won't be divided in
geographical sections the overlay will
just be all the new numbers get the area
codee if you like your 603 area code you
can keep
it so what that means is if you have a
603 area code it shows that you're an OG
Granite
stator so that's not so bad by the way
it could get even worse in in uh
committee we heard about the possibility
of eventually all Us phone numbers being
15 digits not not the 10 that we have
now so at that point are there even area
codes do they even make
sense so let's not spend
$300,000 to delay the
inevitable and let's vote against this
Bill thank you Mr Speaker CH recognize I
request a division vote chair recognize
Thomas thank you Mr
Speaker I don't know about my colleagues
here but I'm pretty proud of the
603 so are our small businesses who have
built their business and marketing on
the 603
trademark now we we know that there are
numbers out there that are not being
used do um doe is currently going
through a process to try to reclaim some
of those numbers but it takes time this
bill will accelerate that process let's
face it you know there's approximately
what 10 million combinations out there
there's only 1.4 million people in the
state if you even multiply that by two
or three devices per per per house
there's still some numbers out there but
they have to be reclaimed now I see
nothing wrong with trying to preserve
New Hampshire's identity because New
Hampshire's identity is 603
t-shirts hats uh even New Hampshire
magazine has columns saying 603 living
603 places you know 603 uh uh uh
resources I mean we built our name on
603 whatever we can do to preserve and
extend the life of our marketing is good
for us good for our small businesses and
good for the identity of the state this
process that we're doing is going to
spend money whether we pass this bill or
not because it's in process this bill
will just accelerate it so I ask you all
please pass this bill it's going to
preserve the New Hampshire identity and
most importantly the small businesses
that depend on it it is worth the effort
to do this please vote green thank you
Mr member yield the
questions does the member yield the
representative Corman has asked for a
members a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
ter
the motion before I saw to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 603 this is a
division vote chair recognized
representative Corman for parliamentary
order against
we had representative Corman speak doing
a pi is that not correct represent no
sees chair chair recognized
representative
MC thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the available numbers for the
603 area code will be exhausted in in a
few years no matter what we decide on
this
bill and if I also know that this bill
authorizes an expenditure that could
reach
$300,000 to hire a consultant to to a to
advise on this fruitless effort would an
now vote no by pressing the red button
uh thank you chair recognize
representative votes for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the state of Maine used a
process almost identical to the one
described in this bill to extend the
life of the area code in Maine area code
207 for another
decade if I also know that this bill is
not about preserving the area code 603
forever it's about preserving it as our
only area code for as long as we can and
there are many reasons
to do that marketing and
otherwise knowing all that would I press
the green button to say yes to Senate
you the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill
603 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if you
oppose you'll press the red button
repr
[Music]
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
257 voting aay 103 voting aay committee
the house will be in
order committee on transportation to
which was referred Senate Bill 471 FN
relative to adding a speed limit of 45
miles hour on Rural highways this comes
without
recommendation representative V moves
pass for what reason does a member rise
471 that is a correct motion the motion
before us is to table Senate Bill
471 division a division has been
I
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill
vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker I don't
know what to make of you're choking on
that for a moment
but Mr Speaker if I know that only a few
towns actually wanted this bill Mr
Speaker if I further know that there's a
process in place for re-evaluating speed
limits where you work with do you get an
engineering study and then in at least
one of those towns that didn't happen
and Mr Speaker if I believe the correct
action for us today is to table this
bill while the representatives in those
districts reach out to their towns and
help them through that process to do it
the way it exists now in statute would I
press the green
button chair recognize your
inre thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill would
came about as a at the request of the
Department of Transportation to add
another tool to their
toolbox and if I also know that some of
the testimony that was uh heard during
the hearing was uh later refuted by the
do namely the cost that would be
involved the the fiscal note attached to
the bill is correct and if I know that
there is an amendment that needs to to
be heard as well would I now press the
red button to defeat the tabling motion
motion before us is to table Senate Bill
471 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
your oppos you press the red button
[Music]
all members pres had an opportunity vot
how attend to state to the
vote 190 voting a 165 voting a Senate
the majority of the committee on ways
and means to which was referred Senate
Bill 4 54 FN act increasing the annual
real estate transfer tax revenue
contribution to the affordable housing
fund having considered the same report
the same with a recommendation to Bill
be referred for inm study Senator Walter
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being un able
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass sen
mle Ley for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to table Senate
Bill
454 the motion the motion is to table
454 division has been
requested members take your
motion before us is the table Senate
Bill
454 say division
vote chair recognizes representative
Sweeney for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the underlying motion on
Senate Bill 454 is to interim study the
bill and if I further know that tabling
this legislation today allows the
concept to still be studied without the
house taking a concrete view on it would
I now vote the press the green button to
table the Bill thank
you chair recognize representative Aly
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that an increase in
affordable houses for the workers in our
state is one of the most
important things that we have not done
enough with in
housing and that this
money if I know that the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority uh would use
this money wisely efficiently and
effectively on then would I
vote that down this tabling motion so
that we can consider the Bill thank
you motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 454 this say division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
members need to be in your seats
all members present at an opportunity to
vote 180 voting a 176 voting a Senate
table house will now attend to bills
committee on education to which was
375 the committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which is referred
Senate Bill 591 FNA act modifying
definition claims procedures and funding
related to the Youth Development Center
settlement fund and claims
Administration having considered the
same report the same with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative Nancy Murphy for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay no the guys haven't and the
committee report is adopted and it's
committee on education to which was
referred Senate Bill 375 an act relative
to biological sex and student athletes
consider the same report the same with a
recommendation a bill be referred for
committee for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make
a motion to
table tbling motion is in
order the motion before us is the table
375 a division has been
not
the motion before us the table Senate
Bill 375 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative belshire for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that there is a very
real concern of a technical uh and
enforcement difficulty in this bill and
if I further know that this body already
passed a bill to the same effect this
year and if I further know that the
reality is that this is the best fate
this bill can have today would I now
vote green a table this Bill thank you
chair recognized representative Simpson
for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that this
body has already passed a similar Bill a
month ago and Mr Speaker if I know that
this body amended the house version of
this bill to remove colleges and locker
rooms and Mr Speaker if I know that two
conservative courts in the past few
weeks have ruled laws like this
unconstitutional and in violation of
Title 9 and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the committee voted 191
1921 for interim study would I now press
the red button to defeat the tabling
motion and move the committee report
Forward Motion before us is the table
Senate Bill 375 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
represent
Buras all members presid had an
opportunity to vote also attend to St to
the
vote 162 voting aay 195 voting a the
motion to table
fill we're back to the original motion
of interim study chair recognizes
leakas thank
you I have a friend who's very short she
was much shorter she had to take puberty
blockers so she could grow enough to be
able to drive a car without special
pedals
Etc and so they put her on puberty block
ERS and she grew to here but she didn't
get any taller she wanted to stay on the
puberty blockers and they said
absolutely not they're
dangerous just on them just the a
minimum amount necessary and yet somehow
magically they're not dangerous if you
want to change your sex only if you
actually need
them we all know that for decades
women's sports they did testosterone
and they would be disqualified if they
had taken testosterone at all because it
gave them an
advantage and yet if somebody has gone
through even the beginnings of
puberty they have that Advantage if
they're a boy but it disappears if they
want to become a
girl um
also if somebody had taken the
testosterone it gave gave them the
advantage and then others would feel
compelled to take it so that they would
still be competitive and that was known
that if you take a hormone that's
different than your underlying
biological sex it is harmful to your
cells and they didn't want to encourage
that so I want to know why we are lying
to our kids telling them that if they do
these things that are harmful to their
body that they can participate in sports
they can become opposite sex of what
they are when your sex is determined by
your chromosomes in every single cell of
your
body while before you're even born and
um so you can take medications that are
harmful for you you can mutilate your
body but you cannot become the opposite
sex and we keep lying and saying that
kids can and therefore we are
incentivizing them to do these things by
telling boys
who have decided to become girls that
they can then play in girl Sports
because they're a girl um we're
incentivizing them to do things to their
bodies that will be harmful for the rest
of their
lives if somebody wants to change their
name their clothes their hair wear
makeup or not wear wear makeup more
power to
them it it because that doesn't harm
kids it just harm stereotypes and
stereotypes getting rid of stereotypes
is a good thing people should be able to
wear whatever they want they should be
able to dress change their names
harmful but
using using hormones which are bad for
your
body doing things mutilating your body
that's bad for you so instead let's
destroy stereotypes not kids and let's
vote for this thank you J recognize
representative
Simpson thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the interim study motion
which have already said the house
education committee voted 19 to1 to
support the uh the education committee
voted this way because this body's
position has already been sent to the
Senate the Senate can choose what to do
but we've already taken a position on
this legislation I'll just share that a
few court cases have had rulings since I
spoke on the floor against hb1 1205 two
weeks ago the fourth Circuit Court of
Appeals issued a ruling that West
Virginia's ban on transgender girls from
playing SP girl Sports violates Title 9
this court is considered more
conservative than the ninth Circuit
Court which rules
similarly judge Toby Hatton wrote in the
opinion that offering a choice to a
transgender girl between not
participating in sports and
participating only on boys teams is no
real choice at all then last week
Montana's Supreme Court ruled that the
state law passed Banning transgender
women athletes from playing on college
and university women's teams was
unconstitutional
I've heard colleagues in this room speak
about how cases focused on bans that
Target transgender teens could go before
The Supreme Court to be clear the United
States Supreme Court had an opportunity
to take a case this past January
regarding a transgender student being
able to use a bathroom corresponding to
his gender and they did not take the
case instead the seventh Circuit Court
of Appeals ruling remained and they
found the policy violated the students
rights under Title 9
and equal
protection for my colleagues who care
about Title 9 equal protections and
fairness this bill violates all three as
we have seen in multiple conservative
courts in the past few weeks we must
study representative na has requested a
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
da
C
the motion before us is interm study on
Senate Bill 375 chair recognized
representative n for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
biological sex of student athletes is
not something we need to study and if I
know that how people feel about
themselves does not change the biolog
biological truth that gives them an
unfair physical advantage over others
lastly Mr Speaker if I know that
fairness is the key word
here then what I then press the red
button to support women like Riley gains
thank you Mr Speaker CH chair recognize
representative Simpson for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that this
body has already passed a similar Bill a
month ago and Mr Speaker if I know that
this body amended the house version of
this bill to remove colleges and locker
rooms and Mr Speaker if I know that two
conservative courts in the past few
weeks have ruled laws like this
unconstitutional and in violation of
Title 9 and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the committee voted 19 to1 for
interim study would I now pest the green
button to accept the committee report
thank you motion before us as interim
study on Senate Bill 375 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 200 voting yay 154 voting nay
committee report is adopted for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker
having voted on the prevailing side I
move reconsideration and request the
no the motion before us is
reconsideration
the motion before us is reconsideration
on Senate Bill
375 are you a division has been
the motion before us is reconsideration
senent Bill 375 if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote how tend to stay the
vote 118 voting A 233 voting aay
reconsideration
fails what reason does a member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion like to take Senate Bill 219 off
you want a division or
something the motion is to remove from
the table
the motion is to
remove Senate Bill 219 from the
table are you ready for the question
division a division has been requested
the motion before us is to remove Senate
bill 219 from the table this is a
division
vote chair recognizes representative
in thank you very much Mr Speaker um if
I know that uh that there's another
motion that would U that would put this
bill to rest and be dispositive then uh
wouldn't I press the green button to
take this bill off the table right now
so that we could get to that thank you
chair recognize representative Sweeney
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know it feels
like deja vu all over again and further
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill was
passed reconsidered tabled so that an
amendment could be brought forward to it
just within the last few hours would I
now vote red to keep this bill on the
table so that more good bipartisan work
could be done so it could come back in
the coming weeks thank you the motion
before us is to remove Senate Bill 219
from the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
nay the bill is move from the table and
the pending question is inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question a division has been
requested roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on Senate Bill 29 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Noble for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that providing this
information to the taxpayers will help
to promote productive local
conversations about
spending and if I know that a
significant portion of the property
taxes that our constituents pay is used
to fund our local
schools and if I know that if we expect
them to continue in to invest in our
local schools we need to provide this
very simple transparency than would I
now press the red button thank you chair
recognize represent luno for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know that Municipal
budget law already requires school
districts to be transparent and provide
significant amount of financial
information to voters when making budget
decisions and if I know that the
Department of Education contain carries
years if not decades worth of historical
information on their website which can
be accessed by anybody with just a
single click so if I've already
concluded that this bill is unnecessary
then wouldn't I press the green button
and support the itl motion thank you
motion before is inexpedient to
legislated Senate Bill 219 this a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
representative
s all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
vote 178 voting yay 172 voting nay the
motion
passes for
what what reason does a member
rise having voted on
the excuse me that was out of order I
don't know who said it but that was
order having voted on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration and urge the
body to vote
no the motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill 29
are you ready for the a division has
motion before us is reconsideration on
Senate Bill 219 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press green
button your opposer press the red button
[Music]
repres all members president I an
opportunity to vote how attend to state
to the
vote 173 voting a 177 voting a the
motion fails chair recognizes a member
from arburn representative Osborne for
third reading motion resolve of the
house now learn from the early session
that the business of the late session be
in order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only
resolutions by caption only and that all
B bills ordered a third reading be read
a third time by this resolution that all
titles and bills be the same as adopted
that they be passed at the present time
and when the house adjourns today it be
a.m. the question is on a third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those those
oppose nay the eyes have it the motion
is adopted
Mr Speaker I arise to a matter of
personal
privilege members stay in your seats
until this is over we're almost
done representative Weber is recognized
for a personal
privilege Mr
Speaker the same representative who
screamed give it a rest at me when I was
speaking earlier also screamed at me
right after session last time time we
met that I was both evil and
stupid and I find that exceedingly
offensive and I would hope that every
member of this house would also find it
order
[Music]
represent representative moves the house
stand and recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills androll build
amendments androll build reports vacate
motion and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppos nay the eyes
have it and the house is in recess until